so I I remember the doctor had ran out
of lube for the ultrasound to see to see
for blood clots in my in my vein or
whatever my body and he's like oh we
don't we ran out of lube and I look at
him I'm like spit on that the whole team
the whole team is laughing then they
couldn't find my vein cuz I'm fat as
[Music]
[__]
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect yo what's up guys I am
Thomas do whatever you want to call me
with my co-host Marty O'Neal what's up
guys guys today we have someone that
Marty and I have been watching something
we think is hilarious this is the Ken
Flores episode thank you for being here
of course man thank you for having me
man appreciate you man thank you for
being here all the way from Chicago oh
you're out in La now yep yep yo okay so
we started talking a lot before we get
started like eight interesting ass
topics before we even started so you
just moved here months ago yeah this
year in April from Chicago in April yeah
yeah I I was renting a room uh when I
came out here for my uncle in San
Fernando Valley and then in August I was
lucky enough to get my own apartment in
Sherman Oaks nice man so I was [__]
happy hell yeah you're from goblinville
yeah what you said before I'm from where
goblins at yeah Aurora all I know is
like Oh Way world yeah that's all I know
you know what crazy [__] is I never even
seen that movie before people were like
oh Wayne's World Wayne world like I just
know it's from Aurora but I never even
watched it before it's hilarious man I
need to watch it I need to get for sure
so you're saying you grew up you said in
Aurora what is that what is that like
cuz you you're a Mexican from Chicago I
recently found out that there's Mexicans
in Chicago last year hell yeah a lot
though I remember they drove to your
meet and greet in Indiana when you at
that meet and greet in I remember
that but uh yeah I mean the thing is
that like people outside I mean even
people from LA are so la they don't
never leave La so they don't even know
know what the rest of the country is
like so for me when I started traveling
people were like Mexican and Chicago
there's no Mexicans in Chicago to me is
like a mindu cuz it's like there a
shitload of us a lot of us you know I
grew up in the north side of Chicago
hble Park area which is predominantly
Puerto Ricans that's kind of where the
Latin King started um my my my childhood
home is actually on a Gangland episode
oh god um yeah yeah so it's pretty it
bright in the hood and then right around
the time I was like 13 14 uh my parents
moved out to the suburbs to about a 45
minute drivve West it's Aurora Illinois
where they did film Wayne's World and
it's still it's it's still Hood it's
still mostly Mexicans you know what I'm
saying but it is just outside the city
so uh it's a little bit I guess you
could say safer and then I I was there
from the moment I was like 13 14 until
right around I was 20 I mean 20 25 26
and then I I left out of there but I I
always represent you know some people
some people that live on the outskirts
of the city they say I'm from La you
know but they're not really from La I
always took pride in being from Aurora I
always said that that kind of molded me
who I am today and and the City of
Chicago shows me so much love they don't
even care that I represent the suburbs
they're like n you're from Chicago you
don't say the suburbs and then people
from La they're like nah [__] that
you're from
La they embrace me you know everywhere I
go and it's pretty cool cuz usually
people are like n you're not from here
or or they they try to take that away
from you you can't represent us but
people everywhere I go they they they
they they wish I was from that City cuz
like I thought you going to say I'm boy
Heights he like Riverside like dude
would bet my money on it yeah people
think I'm from La all the time this
whole time we following you I thought
yeah and and and and I picked up the
lingo too because in Chicago Chicago's
very like Urban uh Urban uh how do you
say uh uh like it's very INSP Urban
inspired so a lot of the people from
Chicago is like New York we all have
this habit of saying the n word oh you
know and and was normal in Chicago but
when I moved out here I realized like
even if you call another Mexican that
they're like hey I'm not that so don't
call me that don't disrespect me in that
way so I was like well I'm not saying it
disrespectfully but at the same time I
realized I got to change my lingo so I
started saying Foo a lot you know which
is the LA lingo so then I would go back
home to CH and I would I used to come
like three four times a year broke as
[__] just used to kick it on my on my
uncle's couch and we used to just drive
me and my homie used to come out here
use like used to save one paycheck and
just blow it all here and then figure
out the bills whenever we got home we
used to just drive up my hole and drive
and just look down on the city like dop
it's like one day man one day we going
to be able to live out here and afford
this [__] but for now we can't even
afford a super eight but [__] it it
don't matter you know so I always fell
in love with the with the city so when I
would go back home I'll say fool and all
this and people are like you're kind of
like not appropriate in culture but
you're kind of stealing their lingo but
it's not even that it's just me trying
to correct my lingo so I don't slip up
on stage which it has happened or in
front of somebody who I shouldn't you
know what a shitty Dilemma to be that's
the East Co thing cuz like where I grew
up like the Arabian kids the Puerto
Rican kids they all just gave themselves
the nword pass and started using it each
othering un up same thing though if
you're Mexican and you're under 35
you're you're probably just throwing
that around like it's just water but I
mean like that's that's just a new bro
you know what it was a bunch of mexic
cette it one day and these black fols
went N I like his
sister and then it just kept going for
20 years and no one ever stopped it and
then they're like he's not he's not
white it's okay got bro what's the color
racist yeah and then amusing now like I
feel like before even as a Cho rapper
Mexican-American rapper you couldn't say
it now we got people like you know dbaby
from Houston Oz from La who say it and
is almost accepted you feel me like some
people do talk about it but it's still
mainstream they got record deals they
got number one singles so it's almost
normalized you know and I'm not nobody
to say what's right or what's wrong but
I'm just saying like do what you going
to do it's evolving you feel me yeah
like Texas yeah it's like saying what's
up man mhm if you're Mexican Mexican
you know what I mean like that's a great
example there's a lot of Mexicans from
Texas that just embrac that [__] but
it's just it's just like the culture
yeah well that's the like I fell in love
with the culture in Houston bro like
people in Houston they got like they got
that like sauce you know like I meant
Mexicans but they got like the diamond
grills
chains with cuz I linked up with those
wolf Peg guys so like d baby Little
Mexico brick wolf Peg and all of them
and just the way they talk is like it's
you're not pretending to be nobody else
that's just Houston like it's Houston as
[__] and I fell in love with that [__]
you know I was like oh it's cool Chicago
we got our own thing too but it's not as
salty it's not as diff it's the South
they always had it's the accents mix
like you're a Mexican with that accent
but you're kind of Texan and then you
got a grill yeah yeah yeah and then the
blacks and the Mexicans and Houston are
real tight real tight we pulled up yeah
sh Barbers got that cut I talking about
last night you can't have that [__] in
Chicago get shot really that's a gang
that's gang affiliated yeah it's called
The Shag now it's called like some other
[__] I guess down south like people got
the mullet have that in Chicago you
can't have if you're if your hair is
short on top and he's long from the
bottom they know you're gang affiliated
yeah and it's funny cuz like like gang
banger dads will have their little
toddlers with a long shag and just walk
around the store you just know that kid
is going over here's DS remember that
one little all shaved and then like a
ponytail just in the middle little one
that's when you're like the dads with
their red shirts with her sons that's
how I grew up like all right all right
dude you're not going to make it past 15
we talking about basically a mullet here
right like the M if you're not white
it's
gang if you're white like you sleep with
your sister type [__] I feel like
Mexican OT could get away with it Bo
Bundy could get away with it still it's
still more like a Buie haircut you feel
me but like if you do shorter on the top
like almost bald or fade and then just
leave it drap it from the back yeah you
going to have problem chago's different
man they check [__] out there for sure I
all right I'm just going to say this I
went to Chicago and went it's the
cleanest place I ever been in my damn
life the downtown is I think it's the
wind it's taking all the trash and
homeless people away bro SW I think it
does cuz I went out there I searched for
homeless people to give this rest of our
food too took us 30 minutes yeah yeah
well that's the thing about also La in
certain cities like Austin and these
like San Francisco like the tender Lo
and like these uh skid R these places
are
downtown because you guys have like the
out like have Hollywood Burbank you know
so you have all these or um where
Disneyland is at or whatever so you guys
all the have all these tourist
attractions that's outside of downtown
nobody's really going to downtown for a
tourist thing yeah that's true in
Chicago downtown is our tourist
attraction so they can't afford to to
have it be dirty cuz we don't have a
Hollywood or anything else you know
makes a lot of sense so we have
Chicago's actually got an underground
city under the skyscrapers it's um it's
where like a lot of dump trucks come in
low uh um any freight trucks that need
to come in and drop off stuff into the
skyscrapers and under there is where the
um like where all the furnaces are for
the big buildings and so what they do is
they build their tents above the like
the heaters where the where on the yeah
yeah yeah so then they stay warm so you
won't see them cuz they're underground
but they're there for sure right I'm I'm
okay with that yo Chicago fix the
homeless situation by like go go deeper
go underneath the [__] it's clean people
just stay out you yeah 24/7 like you can
bu I andan handle and live on the beach
for free yeah all right yeah I'm down
that's why Venice looks like the way it
does it look like this would the cops
let you just set up shop on a sidewalk
with a tent in Chicago if you wanted um
they used to not it used to be real
strict even our bridges our underpasses
on Bridges we put F they put fences up
like it's real anti like home all the
all the bus benches have separations
like very
anti-homeless as of lately with the
Guatemalans and like all the South
Americans coming in they're getting and
I'm not here to get political but they
really are getting dumped into the
cities man and and now you're stting now
you go to a city might not be downtown
but you go into like the neighborhoods
you might see in an intersection it
might be seven eight nine T set up Dam
that's sad yeah and it's crazy cuz you
already starting to see like the change
in culture like the the ladies you know
starting to prostitute themselves and do
[__] like that so it's kind of like this
[__] need to get fixed or it could go
downhill real quick you know but damn I
don't pay attention to anything so I
don't know about what you just said yeah
but but but it's getting it's getting
crazy you know like it's starting to
it's everything starting to be like like
La you know like with the homeless [__]
but mhm did did you watch the first
season of Shamus yeah I did the first
season I did yeah you feel like they
just nailed it far yeah it's pretty
accurate I feel like um obviously not
with the personal issues but just with
like how Cutthroat the show is like
everything is fast-paced everybody's
always like struggling uh you got to
work get home take care of the kid
[__] trains going back and forth It's
Cold very it's a very very a heartless
City I feel like like you either got to
be a tough [__] to make it there
or at least to survive there or you
going to take your ass back home to the
the South or or somewhere soft and [__]
but somewhere soft yeah it's real cut
though I feel like uh the more you go
east from California the more uh I guess
the more cut throw people are like in LA
everybody's High everybody's kicking
everybody having a good time they get
the Vegas people are still having a good
time but now they're starting to go
broke so they starting to get mad and
Chicago [__] just mad cold as
[__] and then you get to New York where
everybody's mad you know like and that's
this is how it goes you feel a great
explanation I think the farther away you
go from fire weed more pissed everyone
get 100% 100% think about it might have
just solved it right here no for real
dude for real we got weather we got weed
there's not much more you need over here
were you smoking in when you were
growing up in Chicago hell yeah I smoked
the first time I ever smoke was in
fourth grade fourth grade K that which
cousin uh yeah it was it was my mom's uh
coworker friend uh my mom's coworker I
mean she had a son and I I remember
getting served and everything bro she
bought a sack how'd you get money no no
my my my homie body like like I was just
like the kid you know he was like in
seventh grade I was like in fourth grade
big as him oh no he was a young skinny
[__] I was just a big teddy bear
I always call myself Snorlax and he yeah
yeah yeah he was just like a scny
[__] and I remember just going
to a house we got served uh through the
second floor window we left the money in
the mailbox
stop yeah that's how you do it over
there you go to the side of the house
put the money in the bottom window they
drop it down from the top window yeahp
of [__] or the I did that once at the
Grove I thought it was a coolu I thought
I invented some [__] I remember went
home took out all the [__] seeds from
the $10 sack and and Spark that
[__] I ain't going to lie I
didn't get high the first time but I
just remember doing it it was crazy
fourth grade huh dut no no no it was
paper it was I think it might have been
like a zigzag yeah so wait you walk no
you you strut back into school the next
day telling all these [__] I
got smoked weed did you did you roll
everybody
rbody worst roll of all time SM I didn't
roll it the kid roll it
up I can't like I mean now that I think
about seventh grade he still a kid I'm
you know I just remember I remember
smoking it but I mean I remember going
the next day to school and telling
everybody and then cuz I was used to be
a Class Clown so I I remember making fun
of this one girl over some I think I had
a crush on her and I used to just
[__] dog dog her ass so then she was
like oh I'm going tell the teacher you
smoke so then they had me by the balls
for like two weeks I was all paranoid
like don't tell nobody but but uh after
a while that's the worst thinking your
hard they go oh I [__] up you yeah
that sucks dude hold on what happened to
that kid that girl oh the guy I mean he
[__] I'm saying did you hang out with
him still uh we he still in our life you
know like um he's he's a grown I mean
the guy's like I mean he's probably like
30 33 34 now he's got a daughter married
some rich white girl her dad sells
Yachts so they always on a yacht
somewhere sells yacht yeah man he uh he
got his one yach yeah he got his uh he
got his [__] together man he got the he
got the right one he sold the weed to
the right rich white girl right H there
hell yeah hell yeah so so before we
started you said yo I used to live in
Chicago then I got in too much trouble
and had to get kicked out to what did
you do um [__] bro like u in Chicago
like smoke oh yeah yeah we can smoke
hell yeah uh I mean it was just like I
used to I I grew up on on Kimble and
it's it's a it's a main uh it's it's a
main uh on Main Street so we get like
CTA which is the city bus that comes
right in front of of of our house so we
just always post it up from the moment I
used to uh walk to school I used to my
mom used to give me like a dollar for
the for the bus so I used to save the
dollar I used to walk to school like I
used to leave 30 minutes earlier and I
will stop by the corner store and buy
like a zebra cake with a dollar or a
honey bun and just eat it the whole way
to school and [__] and that that was my
favorite thing to do and then after
school that my favorite thing yeah my
parents used to work and [__] so I used
to like uh I used to go on into like
this program after school called like
the boys and girls it's like boys and
girls club yeah yeah stuff like that all
poor kids got I went too yeah yeah so we
used to do that and then after that we
justed my mom used to um pick me up and
we used to just be outside all day bro
like post it eventually like as a kid
you're just outside and then like when
you getting older you're like oh we was
just posted outside like and then you
realize like the hanging out with
different people and [__] man I remember
I remember like right around like right
right right after third grade me and two
homies one of them was my cousin the
other one was my neighbor we uh we used
to go outside and um Ball Up Mud balls
after it used to rain and we used to
throw them at cars like that used to be
right in just driving right in front of
us like no no no remorse no nothing like
just throw them at cars and I remember
in one of them uh I don't know who threw
the the the the golden one but we we B
we B up three three mud balls and we
threw them at this car one of them went
through the back window it broke it
shattered and it hit this lady in the
back and we didn't know what happened we
just ran so in Chicago they have the
houses are very uh tall three story
buildings so you can run in between the
buildings so we all ran in between the
buildings and then we come we just like
we we all hidden like I went to my house
and we just hit me and my cousin were
just hiding eventually the police knocks
on our door they get my parents out um
they they leave us in the house they
talk to my parents they shut the whole
[__] block down bro so I was like
what the [__] is going on so I guess we
had um one of us had thrown a rock or
the or the mud ball through the back
window it broke the glass the guy was
driving in the front seat his wife was
in the back seat they were on their way
home from the hospital she had just gave
birth to a newborn baby and we just [__]
the glass just smashed on the baby like
it just landed all over the baby all
over the baby yeah so I mean yeah sounds
[__] up now but so from there my dad
was like you just don't listen you know
like you you in school you're doing bad
you you [__] getting in trouble in
school you getting in trouble at home
like we need to get you the [__] out of
here going to like eventually this
shit's going to turn into like home
invasions or just stealing cuz I was
already starting to steal little [__]
like I became a klepto early
no your mom didn't beat the [__] out of
you bro yeah hell yeah bro stop you it's
just like it's a disease bro like like I
had a good heart but I also I always
wanted [__] that I couldn't have and
then eventually you hang out with the
right homies they'll tell you like you
can have it just grab that [__] and I
just like and then it became like a a
habit where it's like even if I got the
money to spend it I'm going just lean
over the counter and put the Snicker in
my pocket you know and it start with
little [__] then you know you going
through the hummies or not the humies
where your classmates backpacks phones
coming to missing so I was just becoming
somebody who I would hate to be now and
my my pops you know put I remember I
remember the last straw right around the
right around the time that that broken
window thing happened my dad my dad we
used to live in a basement bro in a
basement two-bedroom basement um weom
Bas I didn't heard that [__] Chicago is
three stories bro you get the main floor
the upstairs and then the basement what
people usually do the the homeowners
they'll live in the middle of the unit
and then they'll rent the top unit and
the bottom unit or they have a bigger
family eventually you know rent it to
their kids or whatever usually it'll be
a whole family in one unit and um well
my dad he he he was able to get this
apartment very early when I was born D
near so uh he he he just paay like 700
bucks a month in rent so he was making
okay money at a factory so all the
excess money instead of any Mexican like
saving it he just bought like a Lincoln
Navigator put 24s on it TV screens sound
syst like he pimped it out and I
remember one day um we couldn't Park in
the in the gate uh through the gate so
he left it outside somebody broke the
window took all his [__] all the TVs all
the everything I remember he he went out
to take out the trash all he seen is the
dude jump jump out the window with all
this [__] and and then he chased him him
down and when he chased him down the car
that was waiting for the dude like three
or four [__] jumped out the car
like oh really like what are you going
to do so he just stopped in his tracks
called the cops made a police report
they were like yeah they just hit like
four other houses and then from there I
remember that day my dad had bought a
plasma TV when the plasmas had came out
um and he bought off his coworker who
had got like a newer one or whatever and
and we was unwrapping it we were going
to put it up he came back in the house
he's like wrap that [__] back up we're
getting the [__] out of here and yeah
like four or five months later we he
bought his first house and we moved out
to
Aurora damn that see getting your [__]
stolen will change your life oh yeah for
damn sure knowing you can't do nothing
will CH oh that
that still thinks about it and you don't
you don't want to walk around that
neighborhood like know somebody looking
at you like I got his [__] you feel
that's just like a you feel vulnerable
you know it's literally like a like a
like like invasion of privacy like you
don't feel safe even though you didn't
get threaten or anything you just know
somebody was in your [__] and you ain't
do [__] about it you don't know who it
is yeah he he got robbed a few times but
he was like at a stoplight like I
remember one time he had like a you know
Mexican they buy like gold chains and
[__] he had a nice gold chain he's on
his way to party like on a Saturday at
600 p.m. with my mom [__] just
walked up to the window put a gun to his
chest like take the chain off take the
chain off like it didn't even happen
damn you got to be alert man I look like
I look like like I'm smoking Cris when
I'm driving I'm like
this you have to be bro at the gas
station I look like a tweaker bro I'm
just doing this yeah every gas station
and yesterday I noticed I pulled up a
stoplight was on my phone that I looked
up and the car pulled up next I didn't
see it and I'm like could have been a fo
right there damn I I was not paying
attention holy [__] like I know those
times I'm like you just slipped up man
that could have been it yeah those are
weird dud yeah and it may not even be a
threat but it might be somebody who
going through some [__] mentally like my
little sister she um she had pulled over
to a gas station and this crackhead she
was high as [__] I'm sure you know she
was getting some munchies or something
and some crackhead just went up to the
car and like opened it oh and so she
[__] floored out of there but as she
floored she scraped her [__] doors
off the car so like her car like she
literally drove she had a Jeep but it
was a Grand Cherokee she driving that
[__] like a Wrangler no doors no doors
bro no doors throw that [__] all the way
home told us what happened we couldn't
even be mad like it's your fault you
don't know what you going to do like I
mean as a Mexican you're like [__] it
was your fault but you know damn well
like what you going to do wait and see
what the hell the guy going to do that
you probably know where he's at M that's
the one thing that makes me sad about
these fools like I want to beat your ass
but also like what's it going to do
you're not going to remember and I got a
real soft spot for people like
crackheads and junkies just cuz I had my
own experience with drugs and and [__]
like that so I always I always give them
the benefit of the doubt you know what
I'm saying but like about my little
sister I ain't gonna play about that
[__] you know [__] it get out of there
run over his foot if you got to hell
yeah no no so look
at mered where I'm from it's it's a drug
town so my my spot for drug addicts is
and is is the opposite of you
like I don't got the soft SP [__] well I
I do when they're cool M when they're
cool I look on their face go damn you're
just you're just lost bro but you know
those oh I know I know those junkies
that are just like this guy will give me
money this guy will give me money like
yo you just ask me for money you don't
even remember that's that like I don't
have that soft spot for for I used to do
hella drugs my dad used to do drugs my
whole family used to do drugs so it's
more like you [__] ass fo that's how I
feel cuz like get through it yeah I've
been like day three like up strung out
like
nah it's not for me this is dumb I got
[__] to do so I feel what you're saying
and before we started you you were like
yeah I like to dabble and [__] I've been
in
La the things that you said didn't sound
real so so let's let's backtrack yeah
you smoke weed I I don't do hard drugs
anymore just because like
bro I can't I can't cuz like uh my thing
is like Chris Farley like that
[__] was he was funny you should
have been doing drugs he was you're big
bro that's my uh don't do it that's how
I feel that's that's what when I look in
the mirror I see Chris fartley oh no
stop stop doing drugs please yeah yeah
no I'm trying like I'm trying but but
like there's a documentary it's not a
professional documentary but it's like a
two-hour long documentary it talks about
like like having issues with like
self-control whether it's food drugs
alcohol and validation you know I feel
like a lot of comedians kind of grow up
with the same same type of problems you
know most of them are able to maybe just
stay with liquor the thing with me is
like the food you can't be a fat
[__] and a coke K like you just
fast forward into death you feel me like
you could you could you could do Coke
and you're going to die eventually yeah
but you might have an extra 10 years in
the [__] that slam two double
doubles and then do Coke you feel me the
same day yeah so yeah like I mean with
me as far as like when I started [__]
around with that [__] like I was smoking
weed throughout all of middle school all
of high school you know it was just was
just just to skip school man smoke and
get high go to [__] Cece's Pizza it's
the buffet yeah the buffet High as [__]
hell yeah yeah high as and that was it
that was our day bro and then eventually
when I was like 15 16 I started going to
House Parties we used to call them spots
back home and it was just like I was
always the youngest [__] outside
but people always respected me just cuz
I was always hanging out with the wrong
[__] so it was cool and and I
started drinking early beer you know
Corona Melo was like I was always had
like a 12pack 24 pack the fir the first
time I came to La I was uh like I was
like 177 and they took me to LK
to get a fake ID the swap Mees out here
and I got a fake ID all I did was walk
around be like id id I walked around
like twice by by the second time
somebody came up to me like you need an
ID I was like yeah and I went with some
cholos from San Fernando Valley it was
my cousin my cousin and his homies so
this dude just I paid him uh he's like
200 bucks I'll get you one of the newer
IDs that's one of the new IDs that just
came out and we're like yeah [__] it so
I went with my boys and the dude gave me
the ID after he made it like an hour
later and I was going to pay him the 200
and then my other boy was like [__] that
give him 80
and I was like no but he got it from me
he's like [__] that it's already got
your face on it what's he going to do
not take 80 he's going to lose it so I
was like I feel bad I feel bad but I was
like you right I got 8 for you brother
and then I used that ID bro to to get
alcohol everywhere so then it was I just
became alcoholic cuz now and I'm already
looking like this so anywhere I walk in
they're not going to question if I'm 2
they like oh you just got a construction
job yeah ex nyear old exactly exactly so
then from there I remember right around
the time I was 19 went to this uh this
local this local uh big- time drug
dealer from my hometown uh frea hum and
[__] but he was uh he was like popping
at the time and I remember there was a
Netflix documentary that came out called
Narco Cultura and it did it highlighted
this group called bukas de kakan where
they just basically glorified Narco
culture and they were really big they
were touring all over the country and
this motherf has so much money he had
him come play in their back in his
backyard so he booked them so the whole
city like anybody who was ever picking
up you know QPS or anything from him
trapping we all got invited this was
like this was like a holiday party you
know for theid just stand outside all
the middlemen all the middlemen are
there kicking you know we all feel like
plugs and [__] and then uh [__] they
started pulling out the key bumps and I
had never tried that or I had never even
seen somebody do that [__] but I seen
everybody I respected doing it so I was
like [__] it and I did like two or three
key bumps I ain't going to lie the first
time it didn't even like do anything for
me and then um a few uh a few times
later we did I was like well I already
did it so now I could do it again I
remember the I remember like two weeks
after that um they were doing lines now
this is not a party this is just four
[__] in a garage yep and they
put down a big ass line for me they're
like do it I remember I just ripped that
[__] and for the first time ever I ever
felt like my numb the drip everything
just go numb but it was like back then
Coke was still a little bit better than
it is now even if it was like you know 8
n years ago so I was just like like it
it was like um I mean it's just like
Wolf of Wall Street [__] you hit that
line and it just like you just feel
Unstoppable you know I was like get
taller type [__] yeah I felt skinny and
[__] you feel me like good to that [__]
so from there it became instead of
getting the reup you know getting like a
little QP making a few extra uh you know
100 bucks and getting a smoking sack for
free it became I'm getting the eight
ball or I'm getting the seven and I'm
snoring that whole thing I'm not even
flipping no more I'm just snoring it
then I was just like not even paying
them I was just like I was always like a
week behind two weeks behind sometimes
he'll get locked up then I'll go run up
tabs with like three other [__]
then he'll come out be like I need my
money it was just bad bro I just got
myself in so Much Death that I I got I
drank there's this comedian shout out
Dale MC PE from Chicago he's like I try
to go sober but I drank myself into a
life that I can't live sober oh [__] so
like I was just like I was bad my
parents kind of had disowned me already
they had I had I was sleeping in a I
didn't have a room I had a mattress on
the the floor in in like a living room
and then whenever I had to wake up I
pull my mattress away so in case we had
company or something and I'll just leave
for days you know go to work or pretend
to go to work and [__] and I was just
bad into into cocaine and and [__] and I
I realized um every weekend was just get
my warehouse paycheck I was working at
the O'Reilly's warehouse I'll get i'll
get my paycheck and out of my let's say
$700 bi-weekly paycheck I would I would
use you know $ 20000 bucks for my
eightball another 100 bucks for a bottle
and a 24 pack and then the rest of the
[__] I don't know how it' be gone by the
end of the night and and that was every
weekend that I would get paid you know
so um it I just realized there was times
where we me and my homies that were
doing the same thing we didn't have
nowhere to go cuz then people didn't
want us around them cuz they're like oh
that's the cokeheads cuz Coke wasn't
that accepted back then like nine years
ago we're the only [__] doing
it in public you know and then
eventually um I remember one time we
were just at one of the hom girls
sister's house and she came home she's
like what the [__] are y'all doing in my
house like get the [__] out of here and
then I told the homeo like I think you
said said it was cool but I guess the
girl just ended up breaking into her
sister's house and we're all kicking it
doing coke off the counter so imagine
just coming home and seeing your little
sister with like four [__] just
doing coke she was like get the [__] out
so then I realized I was like bro I need
to do something with my life cuz there's
no way that I'm this much of a people's
person can have this many good
conversations and I'm just ruining it
working at a [__] Warehouse I no
disrespect to anybody that does but I'm
saying like that's all I'm doing and
then when I do have time to be free I'm
just trapping myself in more drugs and
More Death so I was like I need to do
something and that's how I found standup
comedy um like yeah but but but I
already knew I wanted to do something
entertainment because right around the
time I was 15 I I had started doing
random Youtube videos bro really I would
turn on the I would turn on the iPad
camera or i iPod camera and it was
around the time Sergio rosta was popping
I don't know if you remember him he
would be doing like skits like annoying
my mom or super Regal supero the cholos
be like all those videos like on YouTube
they're just like real like Prime first
viral videos from YouTube you know and
it was Latino creators like the original
influencers so I had this one video
called How to Rock a snapback where I'm
just wearing snapbacks like it's like
2009 when whiz was came out MC Miller
and I just put that [__] on my ear like
this like stupid [__] stupid [__] that
[__] went on World Star Hip Hop it went
viral on YouTube oh that sparked you
right there so I got I had got a taste
of the of the of the you're the guy from
that you're the guy from that so I
always had that taste in my mouth but
then you know obviously with the drugs I
got lost and then I was there was
something there was like you your meant
for better than this you're meant for
better than this and I just remember
like my mom just being disappointed in
me and I was like [__] I need to do
something with my life my brother what
really push me was that my brother
didn't respect me older or younger
younger I was the oldest my my brother
like there'll be times where like
they'll go on a field trip and like my
my brother will forget to ask my mom
like I borrow $20 we're going to go on a
field trip and then he'll come and ask
me and I don't got $20 you feel me like
I'm I I don't got $20 you feel that's
just I have a dollar I have four
quarters that's all I got to my name so
I was never able would to be a big
brother for them you feel me so and then
like it got to a point where he realized
that he just didn't respect me no more
he would have an attitude he'll yell at
my mom and I'll be like hey man respect
her like you can't tell me [__] you're a
junkie you're you know so it's just like
it hurt different so I I tried to get
back into the YouTube thing but then I
realized I was like I can't be a fake
[__] like I can't put wigs on I
can't do skits like that's not who I am
and I don't want to be known for
something that I got to turn the camera
on to something to be somebody you know
like you and me I felt like we had the
same energy from before we started to
right now it's the same the same [__]
energ and I was like I just want to be
the same person I want to be known for
being me and apologetic unapologetically
you know and then uh I was but my ego
was like I just don't know how to do it
so I was work at this point I'm working
at a bank at PNC Bank bro I'm borrowing
money from the register when I'm not
supposed to be like I'm like I'm hanging
on by a thread bro and we we we get this
account this guy opens an account he
owns like a se- level comedy club in
Aurora at the Westfield mall and mall at
the mall yeah it's like a it's like a SE
level Comedy Club you know and he came
he came in and he told me he's like um
every time I come in you're real
interesting he's like you ever try stand
up I was like never in my life he's like
you should come and try it come try it
he would always tell me always tell me
and I remember like I never wanted to
try it because at that time the only
standup I had ever seen which is the my
favorite special of all time Cat
Williams Pimp Chronicles 1 someone who
left it all on stage and I felt like no
matter what I ever did in my life I
would never be able to give a
performance like that and also I'm a
grown Little Man by Kevin Hart his first
special ever so I mean those are
Classics you feel me so I was like I
can't top that like I'm or like old old
fluffy you know like his first I was
like bro like what how am I I'm nowhere
near this talented but then again I was
just I knew that I was done with that
life that I was living so I went to the
open mic just to see and I watched like
two different nights and and I ain't
going to lie like it's that ego that you
get where you're just like these
[__] suck like like like like
I'm better than them you know and then
one day I just signed up then and I went
up and you realized oh this shit's
Harder Than You Think You're not better
than them uh at all but I got enough
laughter and I think it's because they
told the audience like hey this first
time so they give you a little bit of
leeway but I went up and I got enough
laughter that again it it triggered that
uh um that addiction you know that that
cuz I get so easily addicted to things
that I like that dopamine that I got
from that first laughter was enough to
get me hooked and I knew that I was
never going to live my life without
doing that again and I would and I would
work with the with the club closely with
the guy and uh luckily people from my
City and Aurora they still remember me
from the YouTube [__] so they always
used to tell me when you going to come
back man when you going to come back man
you were funny you were funny so when I
let them know like hey I'm I'm going
start standup like for anybody that's
been waiting for years I knew I said I
was going to make a comeback you know
when you make a fake comeback but you
never really come back I was I know I've
say I was going to do it for years but
now I'm going do it and I hated that
people recognize me from that video like
I didn't want to be dwelling on the past
you know so I was I need something
that's going to push me forward and then
I just announced my first book show and
people came out and then eventually I
just kept doing it uh in Aurora I didn't
have a car at this time because I was
off so like I had bought myself this
stupid I was when I turned 21 I bought
myself a Jeep SRT8 with the with the
Hemi in I got that O'Reilly job you know
so I got that or so for the first time
ever I was like I'm good you know I'm
going to make my payments I don't pay
rent I'm not responsible for [__]
obiously find out quick you got to pay
insurance gas all that [__] you can't
afford no GPS RTA you can't the gas was
the same as the [__] payment DN near
my credit was dog [__] so my payment was
like on like a car with like 120,000
miles my payment was like a th000 a
month like stupid [__] bro it was it was
like it was meant for disaster you know
they were just looking for you that's
the guy that we going to sell this [__]
they KN I bought that [__] with a bullet
hole with a bullet hole through the door
bro shout out to Integrity Auto Dealers
in Chicago with integrity
that's the name the integrity was the
name of the dealership they got closed
down by the Better Business Bureau for
for falsifying aay stubs and and
basically getting people cars that they
couldn't afford talk about my first car
y they gave me fake fake [__] yeah they
went out of business bro some Polish
[__] some Russian [__] I
don't know what they were right but I
got a bull hole in my [__] I remember
cuz I I'm I'm trying to put the the back
window the back passenger window down
it's not going down I go look at the
door there's like a little hole in it
right like a per perfect hole appear The
Bullet Hole was going out not in so so
we're like yeah yeah yeah so we like we
me and my pops we see this [__] on the
panel we take down the panel there's
like there's you could tell where they
they they covered the whole leing the
door and then they it just had like a
2x4 holding the window up crazy [__] Bro
crazy [__] but yeah and then that [__]
only I my my car got repossessed and my
license got revoked before I got my
permanent plates while it still had
paper plates I didn't even get my plates
before I ruined that got repossessed one
month you didn't pay payment no no no it
took like 3 months you know like like I
I made like one payment bro like and
then my [__] got repossessed like cuz I
was still doing the eight balls every
weekend I'm still like I thought I was
going to I couldn't afford living the
way I was living how the [__] was I
going to afford a car on top and my
Pop's my Pop's cosign for me because he
thought he thought that like um this is
going to be the reason that he
straightens up he straightens up cuz
he's going to know he's want the car
payment like nah [__] when you're into
drugs bro you don't give [__] give [__]
about nothing El it could it could have
been a Rolls-Royce I would let that [__]
got repoed and uh you're explaining the
life of a lot of people I know and my
life a little bit when I was younger bro
yeah and a lot of people like get it cuz
like that's why they [__] with me cuz
it's like it's real you know it's real
like it's real like my real upbringing
bro you feel me from there um [__] from
there I was starting to calm down a
little bit my health was getting a
little bit worse I was getting a little
bit bigger so I didn't want to par I was
getting scared every time I'll do Coke
sometimes I would do too much and I just
you know so I was just like I feel that
double
pump start hearing your [__] I don't
like that [__] yeah so I was just like
you know what I need to I need to start
chilling so then uh I started getting
more in the standup thinking also the
standup is going to free me from the
drugs come to find out everybody that
does stand up does drugs even more than
the [__] I was hanging out with
already so now you just become like is
opportunity so they're like now I could
just man I'll buy an eightball break up
some 40 sacks take them to the open mic
start serving everybody you feel me so
he started doing that for a little while
and then um eventually I was like man I
need I'll still [__] up the reup you
know I'll reup like twice and then I'll
[__] it up know what I'm saying so it's
like I was never I was never consistent
I could never say I was out here pushing
cuz I wasn't it was just I middle man
two deals and then I snort
everything yeah yeah and like 15 through
17 yeah and then um in 200 uh
2019 um I I was already getting I was
getting better you know I wasn't good
but I was getting better I was more
confident I was getting booked at the
the main clubs in Chicago I wasn't doing
like the shitty bar shows anymore so I
was like okay we could have something
here I moved in with a shout out the
homie JV um I moved in with this homie
and he was a video editor and I told him
we we was doing a podcast uh that's what
that's why we had moved in together he
did all the camera work the audio and I
just did the content he'll edit
everything and give it to me and I told
him I was like you know what like we
when Rene vodka and Ralph Barbosa [__]
started to pop off like two years ago I
was like nah like you need to focus on
the standup so we shifted all the
attention from the podcast into standup
clips and literally I would sacrifice
all my money like I would work a job my
boy he was just work in um like
freelancing doing video work so I'll pay
his half of the rent and I was like all
I need from you bro is one clip a week
one clip a week for Instagram let me up
and Tik Tok R bro he had like it was an
invest it was it but he was also my
driver I didn't have a I don't have a
car so he would give me rights to work
so so really he probably losing money he
he would take me to shows too take me to
shows record everything come home edit
you know he gave and that tonight for
instance you're like I'm doing [__]
four shows tonight so you go out and you
when you say he's your driver you're hid
it I'm here for this set that I'm going
to cross town over here for this side
then I'm over here for here and then I'm
finishing off on other side there'll be
times where he'll drop me off in the
front I'll walk in do 15 minutes walk
out he'll hit the block walk out get
back in gone next place and I'm drinking
doing the whole time the whole time I'm
getting [__] up by time we get for
show I'm faded bro but I love like just
remembering those memories now is like
that's what I loved about this [__] you
feel me and then um [__] like it only
took like two videos that for me to go
viral on on the first on the second one
you know your third Tik Tok video has
over a million yeah yeah so it was like
what the [__] and then I had uploaded
two videos that were for my camera roll
one of them was when the fire alarm went
off at Olive Garden and I walked out but
I walked out with my breast sticks I was
like [__] that [__] in case this [__]
burned down I'm going eat my breast
sticks ridiculous ended up hitting me up
for that [__] and they bought the video
off of me oh [__] I mean I should have
kept it but at that time they they
offered me like 200 bucks I was like
give me that I need that that's a
eightball so I
took so I sold him the video that's a
eightball they were 180 over
here like what's the 200 sack what's the
oh it must been fired n n no it's the
bomb it's the bomb [__] now it's 250
that's crazy inflation the [__]
inflation but so I was just like um
anyway so so yeah we we start putting
the clips out sh started to go a little
bit viral and uh me and Renee vodka had
linked up we done some shows together
Martin amini also was another comedian
who who found me on the internet kind of
kind of tapped in with me and then I got
my first um I got my first uh Road gig
in November of 2022 last November I went
to DC I did a show that I did I opened
eight shows for Martin amini and then he
let me headline one so he'll give me the
door deal so it made it worth it you
know and I remember me and my roommate
drove to DC for that first road gig ever
my dumb I took a eight ball my other
homie took like a half a zip in case we
couldn't find weed we get stretched out
in Pennsylvania on the [__] pavement
bro they going through everything I'm
I'm shaking I'm like bro I can't this is
my first road gig ever and I got to tell
the promoter I'm in jail cuz I they got
a [__] aball out of the trunk of the
car the cops searched everything bro
they found a roach and a cart and it's
still marijuana it's still illegal
Pennsylvania oh yeah you said that and
it's like butt [__] Pennsylvania it's
not even Pittsburgh no it's like where
you you can see the iron all over old
scho [__] Hershey Pennsylvania type [__]
you know and uh and um [__] my homie got
hit with a court day with a court yeah
he's you got to come back and just show
up the court and we'll throw it away but
we still going to get hit with it so we
got there and Sh we got everything and
we left we did the shows and from there
they took me to Phoenix the following
month to do another show and I I
remember that I remember that first road
gig I didn't even have no Coke cuz I was
so nervous I didn't want to let any
anybody down but the shows went so well
at the 10 p.m Pro man I was walking
around my hotel hallways like knocking
on random doors like Fe them brother
like I'm like somebody's got to come out
right now and offer me something cuz I'm
like I'm walking around like it's the
projects like but it's just the regular
that's how [__] up I was in the head
feing like a [__] bro and then
um I be pissed you got bump get the [__]
away from my door BR instantly bro oh my
even if you look shot you feel me like
like don't play that [__] you know for
sure you couldn't got shot yeah and then
uh and then from there in January uh
Renee vodka uh he reached out to me
shout out to my boy and he he for the
first time told me like you and me are
going to co-headline some shows at the
haha comedy club in North Hollywood
we're going to break bread evenly and
I'mma throw you something so I remember
I was like cool me and my roommate my
homie chins flew out we did the shows
and I remember first time ever he gave
me $4,000 in50s you all 50s and and I
just remember getting the stack and I'm
with my roommate I'm with my other boy
who was giving me rides to open mics and
just watching me bomb cuz I used to
perform so coked out that my timing was
off tweaked out and [__] so he was like
uh [__] it was a moment where we broke
that bread up you know that 4,000 was
for us even cuz they supported me
through everything and from there we did
New York Boston the following week and
we didn't stop I was featuring for Renee
all over the country and around April um
it was it was a given for me to move out
here because I was getting spots at the
store at The Improv at the laugh actory
Hollywood people from Chicago used to
fly out to do those 10-minute Spots I'm
getting four a week so I can't fly out
back and forth cuz you don't get paid
for that [__] you know so it's just kind
of like to practice but you always want
to be seen right especially show face so
I was like [__] it so I moved out to my
uncles's I rented a room I left my
apartment me and my roommate you know we
split up and I was like I got to go do
this bro he's like [__] it man do your
thing we we we let go of you know we we
finished our lease and that that was the
first thing I ever didn't ruin our lease
nice so I was like I think I can do it
by like I did 2 years of this apartment
I think I could do it on my own so I and
then the rent was going to be cheaper
500 so I came out here and I I got um
started paying my rent started going
around to clubs and um I got disc I
think I get discovered by um arson house
management who manages Joe Koy and
fluffy and then
um Gabriel Fluffy's agent he discovered
me too so I had meetings with all the
agencies on the same week but but but
eventually it was a lot of pressure at
that time I'm also going through health
issues which we'll get into right now
but uh but but but he they ended up uh
you know I ended up signing with them so
I got Fluffy's agent and Fluffy's
manager so they're like this is the
winning team bro he's like you their
goal is to make me into his successor
but I am a little bit different than him
like I'm a little bit more clean version
yeah he's the clean vers but he's like
we understand that we're headed into a
direction where it's more real people
want more raw he's like and you're that
so we're going to we're going to form
you into that but just don't [__] it up
so I was like all right [__] it and um
[__] yeah we've been we've been rocking
ever since fluffy gave me the honor to
open for him in uh Chicago at the United
Center that's your own town yeah he
he private jet private jet got in a G4
I'm sh out to my camera wrote full of
Jet pictures from the one
night I I brought different outfits like
wait wa wait you're in a private jet so
you you could just go like
this lay out bro I hate planes I'm like
that oh n bro plan I had to sit like
this I'm like I want to all on this man
next to me bro I yeah I be I feel I
don't even feel bad for myself I feel
bad for that person cuz I know he going
to hate fat [__] after he s
next to me you know I'm like I'm
supposed to be out here putting on for
the fat [__] instead I'm
bringing us back but uh yeah he put me
on the jet um we I mean we we got picked
up we landed in a private Airport in
Chicago then the his tour bus was
already there so his driver Dave all the
[__] he talk about he's just like
singing in real life he like what the
[__] I got I got I got into a private
jet I saw for the first time Paparazzi
waiting for
him we get into the we get into the bus
my parents they hadn't see me like in a
couple months cuz I hadn't been to
Chicago I've been all over the country
so we pulled up with the bus into the
United Center like the [__] bulls you
know we they had the Bulls had played
the day before so as we parking in there
you could see the hardwood floor and the
and the Nets right there so I was just
like God damn and [__] I mean just
walking in with my parents to The Empty
Arena before the doors open was like I
looked at my dad and I was like man I'm
sorry I got my truck repossessed I'm
sorry I ruined your credit Mom I'm sorry
I did credit card fraud on your car when
I was going through it like I apologize
for everything but like it was like it
almost all seemed to be worth it in that
moment you know and then we did the show
and something happened in between which
I'll tell you off camera but at the end
of the show fluff at the beginning of
the show when fluffy comes out he tells
everybody you know I've been doing this
for 20 years today I got one of your
very own to open up for me km Flores and
in about 20 years I'll be opening it for
him in this very same Arena people went
crazy bro and then after that at the end
of the show he brought me out only
myself not the rest of he brought me by
myself out and there's a video I'll send
it to you if you want to post it or
whatever but there there's um he he
brought he brings me out and he's like
you know 20 years ago I wished my
favorite comedian from my hometown would
have brought me out talking about George
Lopez and and then uh and he said it too
you know so it's not like I'm out here
saying stuff that it's not out there
he's like he's like but you know you
can't force anybody to show you love
he's like but I want to do what they
didn't do for me K is the future can
like all this and then my parents don't
speak English so he looks at my parents
from the stage at this point the Arena's
going crazy cameras is out he tells my
parents he's like he's like uh and to
the parents of Kemp Flores K
Flores your son is incredible so it was
just like like it's like damn like like
it was worth it you know like the
sacrifice or whatever the [__] I was
doing you know all those all these years
and then we got off stage you know it
was sentimental for me but what the most
sentimental was watching my parents come
to the tunnel cuz we were like in the
tunnel like where the Bulls come out and
all the players come out so I'm waiting
for them to come through the tunnel to
go backstage and just see my dad walk
walk in there like with his eyes watery
like breaking down I had never I had
never seen him like that you know never
saw him broke I never see that break
down and [__] basically yeah exactly so
you took it so far so fast we're talking
like this takes comedians a [__] life
in a Year brother in a year in a year
like in January when I was going to New
York when I came out here when I got
those $4,000 in50s I was I went back to
work I went back clocked in you know
what I'm saying I'm posting on Instagram
and then people at my job are coming in
like weren't you in La last night yeah
I'm at work now though like I got to do
it and then eventually one day I was
like it's cheaper for me to fly back for
my paycheck that I'm going to get than
to just stay out here so I just I one
day I just I just left my keys and I
just didn't go back I never put my two
weeks in at a job I always just leave
yeah I don't think I have either
actually yeah I just leave during break
and [__] a [__] Monumental [__]
moment and I tell everybody to eat a
dick in the mouth mhm it's a new year
start 2024 with clean balls don't go
from 2023 to 2024 with the same ball
hair on get manscape today as always go
to manscape.com Yola or use our code
Yola at checkout get 20% off plus free
shipping the New Year's resolution for
every dude out there watching right now
is don't have a dirty dick and start off
the no dirty dick policy with the
performance package 5.0 so introducing
the lawnmower 5.0 Ultra the weed whacker
2.0 ear and nose hair trimmer a crop
Soother aftershave lotion for those
tenderly shaved balls crop preserver and
anti-chafing ball deodorant plus two
free gifts and the shed 2.0 toiletry bag
and the manscape boxers so the 5.0
performance package is stacked it is
also waterproof so make sure that dick
is clean while you're making sure your
ass is clean in the shower so start the
year off right with manscape clean dick
clean balls great year so go to
manscape.com Yol or use our code yolette
checkout 20% off plus free shipping
don't have a dirty dick all 2024 back to
the episode how do you manage your
nerves like still being somewhat new to
Comedy going on in front of a [__]
arena with your like with this Legend
bringing you out like that that's the
problem bro that's when all like the the
Vice come into play cuz now I'm dealing
with nerves so now drinking alcohol you
know I hate I wish I could tell you I
got a [__] fidget spinner or
something but now I got tequila shots
you know we're doing bumps [__]
smoking um food food is the number one
one food is my number one killer bro
like like like the night before I got a
big show I can't sleep like I'm eating
everything bless you thank you but food
and and I hope it changes as I start to
work out and go for walks and [__] like
that um you're in La you got a
girlfriend going on Hikes now man well
[__] I don't know about that but maybe
I'll walk around my building first and
we're work we're work our way to a hike
but yeah like you know like I'm like I
just I remember working out cuz I did
lose a lot of weight at one point in my
my life like junior year in high school
and I mean I remember just never feeling
better you know unfortunately you know
there's trauma and other [__] that
happens that you just eat your way back
into [__] you know I was working at
Burger kinge like 50 hours a week while
I was still in high school I'll would
get out of school early at 1:00 p.m.
just to be able to clock in at 2:00 and
I wouldn't get off to 1:00 a.m. work 11
hours [__] that's some illegal ass
[__] I never heard for sure for sure
they were abusing him I'm right there so
so I get the Burger King I'm was my
first meal Burger King second meal
Burger
ice cream at 8:00 p.m. chicken nuggets
again at 9:00 now it's 12:00 we're going
to throw this away no we're not I'm
taking it home I we're going to pizza
place what it's like when you can make
your own cow on no it gets bad yeah
that's the problem you shouldn't be able
to you should not be able to more cheese
how much cheese can I fit in this [__]
yeah oh yeah you all see like you see
all those commercials like I can make
that I know I can make it and you're
just free for all I worked at McDonald's
too like I'm not throwing away chicken
nugget bro hell no bro I'll put them in
the bag and take them home crazy cuz you
don't even realize cuz you're working so
I remember they used to be like in the
little hot he heat drawers I'm opening
the drawer popping two and like M&M's
another two then I'm looking like damn I
dropped 40 nuggets in the oil and they
ain't [__] left and we haven't sold any
oh I ate 40 [__] nuggets but while
you're moving it's just like drinking
water yeah yeah and then you're
like it's added to this work I know I I
compromise while I'm doing [__] no no
I'm working hard I'm swea look yeah I
worked at an Italian spot I didn't know
alfredo sauce was fattening I kept a
bucket of Alfredo and the bread I just
dip it eat it while I did dishes I
didn't know and I was doing hella Coke
that year and I got fatter doing coke
and everybody make fun like how you can
get fatter doing coke like shut the [__]
up how about that I don't I don't eat a
lot what I do Joey Diaz has this joke
where he's like I'm the only
[__] that gain weight doing coke
I told the plug what you cutting it with
butter oh
[__] I I like the other people can
relate cuz I gained like 45 lbs senior
year while being a [__] cokehead it
got to the point where I was like this
side's bleeding too much paper I'm going
go over this one yeah [__] that [__] I
like [__] I got homies that like their
inside of their nose looks like cheder
cheese brother like looks like craters
and I'm like seum right now I I don't I
don't look at my [__] cuz I'm scared so
I don't even look anymore but there's
nights where like nowadays you know you
get so much fiberglass in the coke that
you'll snort it and it won't hurt right
then because it's numbing your your
nostril but when it starts to the
numbing starts to go away and you're
laying down at 5:00 6 in the morning
trying to sleep it'll just start
stinging like a mon all cut up cut up
yeah it's all cut up I'm going tell you
right now I don't know if that's
fiberglass I think that's called crystal
meth no no no it is that's what I used
to get I I I've tried Crystal men no I
mean cut they cut it in where I'm from
so all I used to do was like get the
grinding [__] and I'm like why is it
kind of too shiny that's not scaly
that's shiny that's is that glass it's
and then remember I told you that one
story where it feels like someone's
cutting your [__] inside of your nose
like someone's trying to climb the
inside of your nose literally and it
feels like you can't stop it and you're
just like I'm about to die I'm going
[__] die the first time my TR crystal
meth was out here bro the same way one
of one of the the first time I ever came
to La is one of my favorite stories to
tell I don't know if I could tell it or
not but tell it all you hear what said
this is uh this is uh when I first my my
uncle who I was crashing with and who I
rented the room for before I rented the
room from him I used to come out and
just crash for like a week you know give
him like a 100 bucks whatever you know
the first time I came out here it was
the first time I met him so I I called
him I was like hey man on your mom or
dad's side my mom's brother I was like I
know you're my uncle I never been to La
I'm coming I would like to meet you um
don't give a [__] about meeting him I
just want to come out here and I pay for
a hotel but I was like is it okay I
crash you know and your in your living
room he's like hell yeah so I remember
showing up that first night and he
already had a a 20 four pack of of
Corona's waiting for me and so we we I
got there you know we hugged everybody I
brought everybody like souvenirs and
[__] is my first like my welcome and
then I sat down with him and he's
putting back beers my my uncle's a
functioning alcoholic and drug addict
more than just Coke so so I didn't know
that though at the time I thought he was
just a drunk so he starts putting back
beers and I'm like [__] this [__] I get
down too so we me and him killed a whole
24 pack like and then we're listening to
coridos and this one specific song
called laa by Lo San reference to
cocaine a lot and at this point we're
both drunk as [__] feing so now every
time the song makes a cocaine reference
we just looking at each other like side
eye you know like yeah side eye and then
eventually he I think he was just like
so what you [__] with that [__] or what
and I was like I mean my my mom's
brother you know I don't want to be like
yeah but I was like you he's like yeah
when when there's some there's some you
know I was like well [__] [__] me
too then he pulls out a and I knew it
was a problem cuz he pulls out a bag it
wasn't even have only seen coke through
clear clear bags this [__]
pulled out like the corner of a Vata bag
like just like some random random ass
and I remember like being hanging out in
the Trap bag with the hummies and [__]
my humie used to have a mattress that
had a plastic wrap and he would just Ser
pull pieces off and serve [__]
like that the V had that little red red
font on exactly brother so I was like
what the [__] so we we did that was
cocaine we did that we finished it and
then um he was like what's up did I get
more or what he I don't got no money yet
though I haven't got paid yet and at
that time you know I told you we used to
cash my I used to have like $700 cash so
I that's a fuckload of money like I'mma
cash out so I I was like how much is the
a ball he a [__] they're like 120 at
that time they 120 out here and I was
like well here's 200 keep the change get
the eightball let me get it okay cool at
this point it's like 5 in the morning he
leaves bro he leaves and I'm just CED
out of my mind no more alcohol so I'm
just sitting there it's like 6:00 in the
morning he comes back bro he comes back
back he gives me the fat ass bag I go
into the bathroom he goes into the room
I was like he's going to call it you
know but I was so thirsty like I open
the bag up I'm crushing [__] down but
like you said it's kind of like sugar
you know it's not it's not really like
powder anymore and I I do a bump and it
just [__] stings the [__] out of my
nostril yeah bro it hurt instantly I
feel like somebody punched me in my face
and and then I was like you know what
[__] it let me do the other one just to
make sure so I hit the other one too and
as I hit the other one it just [__]
stung bro so I walk out the bathroom and
I told my Uncle I'm like hey what is
this and as I see him this [__]
is already in his work uniform he got
his hard hat on orange uh [__]
traffic vest like he going to I was like
bro you haven't even slept he's like
yeah man you got to work man you got to
work so he's and I was like what is this
he's like oh it's a it's k k he called
it k k and I was like what the [__] is K
he's you don't know what k k is I know
he's it's Crystal math and he said it
like dummy you know and I was like what
Crystal me I was I never done Crystal me
he's like yeah man he's like they didn't
have no more
coke I why you ain't call me like you
ain't think to check in like you just
took my 200 and put it in other drug
that you thought I'll would be okay with
he's like I mean if you don't want it
you don't want it but I mean there's no
returns and the [__]
bet I mean this is like a from my aball
this is like we're talking about like a
like two golf balls you know like $200
in crystal meth is a lot of crystal meth
cuz meth heads don't have $200 to
[__] waste on meth so it was a lot
it's like we damn near bought wholesale
bro so I'm like well I mean either these
$200 go to waste or I do this [__]
crystal meth when you're so deep in it
you're like [__] it so I kept snorting
it I kept snorting it now it's like 2 3
in the in the afternoon right I'm yacked
out of my mind my aunt went to work
nobody's home I don't know if y'all ever
done crystal meth but that [__] make you
horny my dick is rock hard bro I'm
sitting in this living room by I'm bro
I'm just dick hard as hell and I'm
looking around the [__] house it's
like Virgin Mary's everywhere [__]
Jesus uh an America calendar like crazy
[__] you know gold plan bro crazy I'm
just like what the [__] like this has
got to be a sin like just having my dick
harded [__] looking around all these
Saints and [__] so I was like and I I
felt like I couldn't whack off in the
bathroom cuz that would be disrespectful
but even though I just did crystal meth
in the [__] bathroom so I was like
you know what like some's got to I got
to do something and I had homies back
home that had hired escorts before and I
had never done that before but at at
this point I'm off Crystal myth I'm
desperate and I still got $500 left so I
I look up Google I'm like escort's near
me and this uh this you know it's like a
at at the time the website was called
erratic monkey I remember that [__]
erratic monkey was the name of the
website and it's like eBay style you
know I don't want to say eBay style yeah
cuz back page was already gone it didn't
exist but this is like the new thing
right so like it just gives you like the
ad headline details and then you click
on it if you want more right pictures or
whatever and I remember just like being
on a budget I like you know what I'm not
going to spend more than 100 so I was
going through I put a filter like $80 or
less and like that's a scary game bro I
swear I clicked on I clicked on like the
first one and it was some chick right
and she she you know first of all I
texted like 10 of them [__] you text
them all yeah I texted like 10 of them
bro text Bro then the text start coming
back yes I'm available how much how long
do you need and at this point I don't
remember who the [__] I'm texting cuz
it's just like I'm not going to cross
reference numbers like I'm in page 62 of
this [__] you feel me like I'm [__] so
so I just [__] uh I I just the one
that that responded the most uh fastest
I was like well where you at so she
gives me this address is it's the Costco
in Van Ice Costco and Van Ice so there's
a Costco Costco in so so this is the
address I got right she's like she she's
like she's like I'm in the apartments
across the street from the Costco pull
up to the Costco so I get a uber as I'm
getting the Uber the Uber pulls up you
know I'm still rock hard my aunt's
pulling up too and so I cross with my
aunt now I'm sweating I'm pretty sure
the house smelled like ass cuz I've just
been cold sweat in there all night and
then my aunt's like where you going I
was like oh I got a friend who's also in
town from Chicago he wants to meet up
for coffee or some
[__] bullshitting bro I was professional
bullshitter and she looks at me and
she's like um you don't want to ride
give you a ride I was like nah no I'm
good like Uber's already here I jump in
Uber the Uber go from San Fernando to
Van nice which is 12 minutes or some
[__] like that we get off the highway
now we're coming down this dead end to
my right is a Costco with a gate a dead
end straight ahead and then Apartments
to my left and also we're going down the
street on the parking lot is like 10 RVs
bro just hella RVs right all people
living in them you know so we get to the
end of the dead end and the guy the Uber
driver just looks at me and all he says
is be careful and I get out so I'm just
like [__] like I don't like that you
know he obviously said that [__] for a
reason so I text this girl I'm like hey
what apartment is it I'm here and she
text me back hey I'm sorry I just got
back from doing groceries let me put
this food away and I'll text you the
apartment number right now I'm like cool
but I didn't want to stay in the dead
end so I start walking up the fence
along the Costco and I'm trying to get
to the parking entrance I was like you
know what I'm just going to get into the
parking LW and I'll go into the Costco
and as I'm walking there's there's guys
just coming out of this one RV and and
in my head I'm so Crystal out I'm like
is the feds like the feds are the feds
are are out to give me for the $80 [__]
you feel me like I'm [__] so I'm
nervous and [__] so I like speed walk
past the RV and I get to the left and
I'm walking towards the Costco front
door and I'm like you know what I'm
starting to come to my senses I was like
I'm just going to get a slice at the
Costco a pizza and I'm Uber the [__]
home like I'm I'm out of my [__] mind
right now as I swear as I'm about to go
through back
bro as as I'm about to go through the
front door bro I ding got the text
message she's like hey I'm ready so now
the devil is like the devil angel on my
shoulders like now get the pizza fat ass
and like n get the [__] you can still
get the pizza after the [__] so I'm
just like [__] how long does a bump a
MTH last your like [__] like two days
bro I didn't even sleep after that [__]
so so now I'm so now I hit the I hit the
I hit the [__] so I turned around now
I'm walking towards the apartment and
I'm telling her like all right what
apartment is it like I'm sorry I don't
know which one it is she's like oh I'm
not in an apartment I'm in the RV so I
was like what RV tells me exactly the
one what RV you asked yeah cuz there's
10 of them no I'm going to
go n I'm too deep in I got you you got
to see it through my
boy so so so uh she's like I'm in the RV
the one she with the details I knew
that's where the guy had came out of oh
so I was like bro like this is a setup
this is a set so my head I'm like this
is a setup but my body is autopilot I'm
I'm not stopping you know yeah and and
I'm and I'm walking past I'm walking
past the RV she swings the door open I
was like nobody comes and gets me I'm
not walking in and I'm not knocking the
the door swings open and it's her it was
the lady right I don't remember how she
looks at this point I don't know who the
[__] I'm texting cuz I texted like 10
[__] you know I don't know who the
[__] is the one that replied so then um
yeah so then she's like come in baby I
was like okay so I come in the RV bro I
lit literally right so I come in the
RV the first thing I see bro the TV the
regular shows playing you know the I
look to my left there's a baby on the
high chair oh my God bro I swear to on
my mom's life this is 100% facts brother
there's a baby on the high chair bro so
I'm just like bro I'm happy it's not the
feds but I'm like a baby so she's just
like go to the room I was like all right
so I go to the back there's a room and
I'm like I'm a big [__] I'm
getting through like these little RV
doors like sorry baby bro I'm lit
knocking [__] I'm knocking [__] over bro
you know the baby looking at me like
this fat [__]
stepping yeah what the [__] this
[__] and I get to the back and
she white lady uhuh Salvadorian oh so I
was thinking I was just expecting a
white a white baby with dirty feet
Salvadorian
lady and uh and when I get to the back
there's a towel laying on the bed and
I'm just like oh she probably just took
a shower put the groceries away I'm move
the towel bro his [__] stains all over
the [__] bed I was like [__] so I
just put the towel back bro and she's
just like get naked and lay down over
the towel so I you're too deep in bro I
didn't going to lie I got naked I got
naked it's still 300 p.m. so like the
sun is beaming through the window so now
I'm a big guy I'm insecure as it is I
don't get naked even around my girl
until it's dark so now I'm in the middle
of the day just naked laying on a random
bed in an RV and Van Ice she comes back
in the room bro she tries to uh what's
her demeanor like like when when you saw
her were you like oh okay okay were you
like oh this [__] is [__] insane
everything was like processing at the
moment and once I was naked laying down
like this it all hit you I sobered up I
sobered the [__] up and I why am I here
what what is wrong with like I'm I start
thinking about all the times that like I
let my brother down the first time I
smoked weed like when they robed my you
know like when they like all this [__] I
was I just told you earlier it's just
flashing through my head like how the
[__] that I end up here you know she
comes in the room she closes the door
doesn't even waste no time just get
straight to sucking my dick bro and at
this point my [__] is just flaccid like
it's dead like I'm not this is it's not
going to happen bro scares me it's not
yeah scared it away and she's like um
why you n you nervous I was like yeah
she's like your first time I was like
yeah and then she's like um all right
well how about you I kiss you and you
basically jerk yourself off so I was
like all right [__] it whatever so I go
in for I literally going for a kiss like
I'm going to make out with this [__]
escort prostitute whatever you want to
call it but this [__] starts sucking on
my titty bro just put my puts my whole
titty in her mouth that [__] was fire
too that [__] was good she's sucking the
[__] on my titty bro and I'm like
starting to get hard again and
eventually you know I just beat my [__]
until I nut it and I I paid this [__]
80 bucks to suck my titty while I jacked
off bro I Crystal M I swear that was
that was the end of it I walked out said
what's up to the baby and I got a slice
of pizza and went home brother no
chicken bake no chicken bake I didn't
even know that was a thing I just
learned about that actually yeah man
crazy real life 307 bro right no time at
pass 37 the show hasn't gone to
commercial the baby still got a spoon in
his head yo this was the most deep I can
see everything I can see it all but like
I said it's real though like I'm
explaining to you so you can walk it
through with me yeah I'm living as I'm
telling you I feel you that's you even
get
like start to feel grossed out as I'm
going to tell stories I get get like I
get like nasty cuz I'm like I'm there
bro I'm here you wen't
yeah did did this kick off a whole spree
of these kind of
situations your slight smile [__] not
not not hiring girls but just I would
now I even to this day I'm ashamed to
say it but if I'm in a different city
I'll look it up you know like I know the
websites now but I will never go through
with it cuz most of the time I'm geeking
or something and I'll just be too
paranoid too and now as you start you're
recogition starts to grow I went to a
[__] Dive Bar in back home in Chicago
in Stone Park and where like it's not
even a strip club it's just like dirty
[__] that retired from the strip club
and you give them like $8 and they dance
on you at at a bar you don't get no
private room no poles no throwing money
nothing you know just little hoes
dancing and uh I was at one I was at one
of those places and a few of the girls
recognized me they're like you're that
comedian I was like no I'm not I was
like no I'm not no I'm not I'm not fun
they pulled out pictures of me and them
like at the Mee and green I was like so
now I'm very like I don't want to get
recognized you know and I'm doing some
shady ass [__] like that so now I just
like I got myself a girl now should calm
the [__] down and and get my [__]
together level the [__] out cuz I also
had like health issues too where I was
partying too much like you start getting
money for the first time and you just
start everything's an excess like I'll
I'll drink from Thursday through through
through Sunday morning you know like at
7:00 a.m. on a bender a bender you know
a bender then by Sunday um
I'll I'll have to sleep all day cuz I
haven't slept in three days this [__]
just happened to me not too long ago I
don't want to tell you how long ago it
was cuz embarrassing but I hadn't slept
like in 3 days and I was in the shower
showering and I fell asleep in the
shower and I fell out of the tub and I
busted my [__] like I'm just I was I
need help I was I need to get my [__]
together you feel me and and and it
happened to me multiple times where I'm
knocked out like I won't fall over over
some like fainting or anything it was
just that I'll literally go to sleep
standing up and it'll shut down like my
knees will lock and I'll pass out I'll
wake up right away cuz like what the
[__] I just busted my [__] but but yeah
like that [__] happened but um what was
happening uh what was happening was that
I will go on a bender for three days and
then on Sunday I'll sleep all day and
then on Sunday night I'll just cash out
like on dominoes or some crazy [__] and
everything I didn't eat in three or or
four days I put it down in one day and
it's just like there's no point like at
least if you're going to be a junkie
lose some [__] weight you feel me
like you're just a junkie and then
you're eating twice as much when you're
not [__] up you know so my my body
just couldn't take it on top of that I'm
traveling I just did like like a month
ago we did six cities in six days damn
yeah we did Nashville Huntsville
Colorado Springs Denver Albuquerque and
El Paso flights every morning and it was
just like and on top of that we hung
over like your body just going different
time zones different altitudes in
Colorado sh [__] me up [__] you up I
got sick I got that altitude sickness I
never knew it was real bro yeah like I I
had friends that were in shape that we
will stay on the same hallway of the
hotel and they'll come to my room and
they'll be like damn before I have to
knock I have to take a deep breath cuz
I'm almost out of breath walking from my
room to your room I is that [__]
altitude especially me I'm already
having a hard time breathing now with
that [__] I was up there like getting
suffocated I remember um I remember like
my birthday this year uh June I had
Phoenix for the first time I'm headlin
in Phoenix we did three sold out shows
and um every every day that we did the
show so it's three days straight every
day the the manager would greet me with
a eighth of some loud I think it was
like alien something and then uh bottle
of CAS Amigos sick ass and every day
I'll drink it myself the whole fifth so
I'll get [__] up every day bro and
then like and then I was still pounding
Twisted te's down and [__] like that and
then my body was retaining liquids and I
didn't know cuz my heart my I had high
blood pressure and I never looked into
it so now I'm doing cocaine and I'm
drinking and I'm eating so now all all
this blood is backing up because it's
just not leaving my body as fast as I'm
putting it in I'm not peeing enough and
[__] like that so now I'm getting like
um I'm losing my voice because like my
my my it's connected to it's all
connected to your lungs and [__] so my
my voice was kind of missing and so now
I can't do shows so I'm getting worried
cuz I'm like I don't got stripped
through but you can't hear [__] that I'm
saying I have I have videos that went
viral sounding like that you you know
and then uh and then on top of that I'm
out of breath like shortness of breath
was insane like I'm a big guy and I've
always had shortness of breath I'm not
going to lie but I'm talking about we
were in New York and I couldn't go from
the lobby from my room to the lobby
which is only like four Steps From the
door to the elevator and then from the
elevator to the front lobby like I
couldn't do it by the time I got to the
front I was like so winded like I was
going to pass out oh it was bad bro and
I had got on a plane from LA to from LA
to Philadelphia when I hit the east
coast and that sitting in that plane um
I cut like blood clots so my legs I got
swollen as [__] bogus as [__] you know
so I couldn't breathe my legs are so it
was bad bro you just feel like I can't
did this I did this yeah I did bro I I
feel you cuz I have horrible back so
I'll be sitting there like I did this
[__] yeah and you start reflecting you
know and yeah but it literally takes to
that point and from there we did shows
in Philly Jersey and then we did five in
New York by the fourth show I was
performing and I called it I was like I
was going to go to the hospital the next
day at LAX when I landed I couldn't I
left the hospital that night I went to I
was in Manhattan I hit the hospital and
as soon as I got to the hospital like
they check my blood pressure everybody
freaked out they about the whole [__]
I never seen it go down like that you
know I've been in car accidents and [__]
like that I never seen like the team
come out like in the movie but like they
check my blood pressure they're like oh
[__] they brought the whole [__] team
out they put me on the bed they [__]
take me all the way to like trauma or
some crazy [__] and critical ICU for the
heart thing they start they start giving
me ultrasounds they they're and I'm
still funny like I'm still me so I I
remember the doctor had ran out of lube
for the ultrasound to see to see for
blood clots in my in my vein or whatever
my body and he's like oh we don't we ran
out of lube and I look at him I'm like
spit on that [__] the whole team the
whole team is laughing and [__] then
they couldn't find my vein cuz I'm fat
as
[__] so I got like four different
[__] just poking the [__] out of me
bro inverting you and [__] bro I
remember they called this one guy he was
like one of those guys that like he's
got like a big beard with like the nice
gel in his hair the all the nice
colorful Marvel tattoos you know one of
those like hipsters and [__] he he comes
in the room he like oh I got this he
gives my [__] he stabs me a big ass
needle and then he leaves like 10
minutes later my hand is swollen as [__]
he missed the vein so now my whole hand
is just full of IV liquid [__] I
take it out I start bleeding everywhere
it was bad bro it was bad and um and
then they told me that's when they told
me like you know what you got blood
clots you got high blood pressure and
your body's retaining liquids so we're
going to give you lasx to get rid of the
liquids so we can you could your legs
can get unswollen my legs were bro my
legs bro I can show you right now one of
my my legs are swollen I'm trying to
slow down but it was bad bro like my
[__] was like you could just like break
it off like it l like a [__] uh one
of those toenails that dies and [__]
like bad bro and then uh from different
color and [__] type yeah bro it was like
blood it was like purple black bad bro
bad bad and then um they kept me they
kept me in the in the hospital for like
a week bro and then Ralph Barbosa you
know Ral he was on the podcast he came
to visit me and he was like bro um I'm
doing a surprise show with Chappelle
tonight if you get out on time come
through I'm a comedian bro I F no what I
told I was like I'm out of here wrap all
this [__] up they're like no you need
your I was like ah I'm about to meet
Dave Chappelle [__] I'm don't give a
[__] so I signed um to leave against
medical advice all that [__] they gave
me my my prescription for medicine to to
start taking I left bro I I never got my
medicine I went to the show that night
enjoyed it was a hell of a time then I
flew back to LA then I flew to Chicago
the next day cuz I had shows in Chicago
that weekend then then I flew to Miami
cuz I had shows in Miami so now I'm in
so now I'm feeling good cuz they just
took care of me in the hospital so now
I'm back to square one I'm breathing
good my legs aren't swollen so I go
twice as hard in Chicago three times as
hard in Miami cuz I never been to Miami
Capital cocaine capital of the world and
[__] like we were hanging out with porn
stars they took us to tootsies that that
strip club Drake we talking about all
that [__] bro got the whole treatment
you know and then from there um it's
good you and Goblin never cross path yes
we would have died for sure we would
have yeah it's good it's good and then
from there um from I went back to LA I
swear to God I was only there for like a
week before I had to go back to the
hospital cuz now I'm spitting up blood
what the [__] yeah yeah like Miami
killed me and I went to the hospital and
when I went to the hospital I was still
off cocaine I had I hit a bag before I
got my Uber to the hospital bad bro bad
I get to the hospital I tell the guy the
doctor that receives me everything that
happened in New York everything I did
from New York to now and what's going on
now and he was like he was was like he
was like you you're 27 years old he's
like you're 27 years old you're young
you can fix this but your heart right
now I've got patients that are 80 your
heart is performing like at a fraction
of what their heart is performing he's
so they wanted to give me like a vest
that like shocks you like I'm on some
crank [__] you feel me like like to
bring me back to life in case I was like
my heart was to start beating you
regularly and on top of that he was like
you're on cocaine right now I was like
no I'm not he's like I can see it in
your nostril so I was just like [__] D I
just
wasted damn it that was embarrassed it's
funny but it's bad yeah yeah you know
but it's real though and then from there
um it was bad cuz now the blood clot
[__] was getting a little bit more
serious cuz now I felt weird in certain
spots where I just start feeling weird
you know and I didn't know how serious
that [__] was until I was laying in the
hospital bed looking it up I was like oh
I I could die at any moment you know and
then uh bro it was so embarrassing like
on top of that when you get on blood
thinners you you [__] yourself like any
any any any um excess force that you do
you [__] yourself cuz now you're on
Lasix which is just pushing fluids out
your body and on blood thinners which is
just C your blood like your body just on
Med medication there's this girl fine
ass nurse that came in the [__] fine
ass nurse came in the room bro and she's
telling me like um oh I know who you
are we're watching your videos we're
watching your videos right here with all
the nurses woo woo she you need to hook
us up with tickets I'm like yeah I got
you I got you and they're not letting me
drink water because um they don't want
me to drink no more liquids they're
trying to get everything out of me so um
so then she she she um I was like do you
think you could so I was sneaking to the
bathroom and drinking water out the sink
cuz bro you don't know how valuable
water is until nobody lets you drink it
it just becomes like the best thing in
the world I don't care if it's tap water
or whatever so she she's like okay I'll
let you go to the bathroom but just
don't drink water just use the bathroom
and come back so I all right cool so I
get up and she's helping me get up bro
and as I make the final step to like get
off the bed I just hear my you ever fart
and you just hear the cheeks like open
and Clos real quick like a clap like it
was just a quick clap and I was like
what the [__] and now we're wearing
those hospital gowns with split open
split open in the back so me and this
girl we make eye contact then we both
look at the floor it's just like a
perfect Hershey's Kiss pile of [__] on
the floor bro for real
I just looked at I was like I'mma hook
you up with the tickets for sure for
sure I'mma hook you
up and ever since I got my medicines
when I left out of there and I've been
taking them ever since and slowing down
man get my iin trying to
die I'm sorry had to come to that no no
cuz I I can imagine it it's a perfect
little [__] I bet she didn't she wasn't
even fa right I just she wasn't that's
the thing but like she's a nurse she's a
n she she's like hey this guy's hilar I
just saw him take a [__] on the floor
but he's funny yeah but the crazy thing
is that she told me just lay back down
we'll come clean you up I was like [__]
shut up not going to do that no do that
I I got this I'll die in the
bathroom [__] that
[__] so but you things are moving in the
right direction
healthwise yesr they were I haven't been
to the hospital since this was I so I
went to the hospital the first time in
June the second time in July right the
month right after so as of right now no
I haven't been back to the hospital um I
was I started to go I started to make
the most money I ever made uh on night
and doing certain shows so I started to
like like I bought I got my first
section at a club for the first time I
started doing [__] for the first I went
to a nice restaurant for the first time
so then it it became to a thing where it
was like a celebration like a
celebration everything you did was a
celebration you know and then you
realize cuz then I I used to go to The
hollyood Improv at The Comedy Store and
I see people that I look up to on my
idols and they walk around drinking hot
tea and I'm like these [__] [__]
you know but then you realize like if
you want to do this [__] for the long
run longevity you're not going to drink
every time you have a good set it's your
[__] job you should have a good set
so then I kind of started going into the
realization like okay yeah maybe there's
some ni I need to take off and um yeah
and that's what I'm starting to do now
and uh I was I was doing really good
especially my girl moved in and [__] but
she left for for Christmas and on the
first night she left I got invited to
random as hell uh ber Cher you know he
hit me up he's like you want to do
something's burning um the his cook
showcast was it's like a show podcast
yeah where he cooks yeah so I'm like
yeah what the [__] you're one of the
biggest com in the world so then I did
that and you know he's known for
drinking from I don't know if I should
say this or not but I thought he wasn't
drinking at the moment that's like the
the thing in the comedy world is what
they're saying like he took a break from
drinking so I was like I'm not going to
drink we're good and as soon as I got
there he's like you want to drink I was
like n if you're not drinking I'm not
going to drink he's like I'm going to
drink I like [__] it then let's get it
we got [__] up we partied hard and
then from there I just went on that
Bender matter of fact that's when I
busted my [__] in the shower oh
no yeah but it was almost worth it I was
like hey I don't give a the episode's
not out yet but as you're on your back
like you know what there's a great it
was a great episode worth it people are
going to see it like even if I die right
now I'm a legend you feel me
like no yeah but yeah I agree with you I
say it all the time I I used to do Coke
a lot
like like what you're
saying it like the way I smoke we you
watch my videos the way I smoke we is
the way I used to [__] be cold and it
was not good for us but I stopped doing
it at 22 and the maybe you needed to
happen I got the last time I ever did
Coke I got a [__] sinus infection
from it but the ones where it throws off
your equilibrium I couldn't stand up or
talk or move for like almost a week and
a half and every time I moved my head
was just doing this what the fu it threw
off my equilibrium and I got an
infection behind my eyes my homie gave
me some [__] yeah [__] I don't know
what happened but I got tired off it and
I felt like weird I don't know what
happened it was a long time ago and I'm
like I'm going to stop doing drugs today
I don't I can't feel that but and then
it was like I'm too I got to what I say
I got to get in shape so I can do some
drugs in the back flip I've been saying
since season one because I I can't let
it mix like you said you can't mix it
you can't be a big ass fool and then do
drugs you got to do drugs and be like
I'm skinny I can wear coats and butt
them you know once I'm like that where
I'm sitting like I can see straight down
yeah I'll just you yeah and it was funny
cuz like when I when uh when the whole
Co [__] went down or whatever I got my
vaccine or whatever but I also got a lot
heavier and then I'll do Coke and I'll
start feeling weird like in my chest you
know vacine and I'll would be like the
vaccine but I I even got a bit about it
on my standup and [__] but it's like
sure you know like sure vaccine you're
400 [__] pounds brother like that
ain't the vaccine that's the hot pockets
and [__] you've been eating I've never
related so much in my life I was doing
drugs and [__] like no it's definitely
not all the [__] I ate cuz that's
that's what I would do I'd be up for a
day drinking smoking sigs chilling my
homies then smoke some weed to be like
oh we're out of Coke I'm going to smoke
weed we're going to hang out and then
when I wake up I'm not going to wake up
I'm wait till [__] opens cuz that's five
once McDonald and all this [__] you're
allowed to walk in we go there and spend
like $12 the dollar menu cuz I haven't
eaten in it since school like school was
yesterday full it's Sunday morning yeah
yeah and then that's my life cuz I used
to work at a pizza spot and just i' be
selling Sachs doing drugs and I feel you
it catches up to you man yeah man it
does just start to feel
like I could be buff man I feel it I
know I could and then when you're on one
you're always like I'm going to get on a
regimen tomorrow and just be rocked out
and the next day you're like Domino's is
only $7 or mediums yeah man it's like
the the cown you I've be getting my life
together on the cown like from from like
6:00 a.m. to 9:00 a.m. when I can't
sleep and I can't eat yet cuz my teeth
are hurting from grinding all night long
I'm just like n man I'm tomorrow I'm
going to go for a walk I'm going eat a
salad I'm I'm going to wake up early go
on a hike and then you wake up and it's
then you feel like different you already
came down and you got some rest like n
[__] that [__] what we going to Yum Yum
Donuts you feel me like well I got [__]
to do I'm going to start that [__]
tomorrow and then you're like I was 17 I
said that I'm 28 yeah it just keeps
going that's the I I've for all the
people out there going yep yep yep it's
the Dilemma Marty you don't have it in
your head cuz Marty's an in shaped
person it's not that you don't want to
do it I have it in my [__] head you
do oh for sure oh okay okay so here we
go sorry to exclude you from this it's
more like this it's like uh I could do
that right now or I could do something
else that's maybe more productive in my
life because I don't cuz you don't look
at yourself if I can see my myself all
day but hey well I'm going to get on the
treadmill and then I'm going to go get
high as [__] today yeah that's how I
feel but I can't I only look out and
this looks sick yeah and I also like
yeah I also think I look different than
what I look you feel me like have the
antibod dysmorphia [__] yeah yeah like
in my head I'm like I'm like I'm like
now I'm buying shoes buying pro clubs
buying a nice pair of black Levi in my
head I'm like in my head I'm looking
like you know what I'm saying like
somebody in shape and then I put the
[__] on I'm like what the [__] wrong
with like why I look like a [__] ball
you know and it sucks but then you
just you know just not enough to help
you get your [__] together but it is for
me now cuz now it's like even even
coming like the past week uh I told you
my girl was gone she just got back
yesterday and I was feeling like [__]
like I couldn't even sleep laying down
like cuz I could feel my like just I was
bloated you know I so I before I came
here I bought some over the counter um
water pills for the blo for the water
retention and all that and I'm taking
them and she was just mad cuz she's like
I told you like I was already good you
know I was already good but it's like
when you start feeling like this like
you can't even [__] you can't do [__]
cuz I can't even leave I'm leaving my
apartment I'm getting into into into the
elevator I'm just
like you know it's just like oh you're
still feeling it right now yeah yeah
yeah like yeah so it's just like I mean
I'm getting it's getting a lot better
cuz I used to not be able to even do a
podcast I wouldn't have been able to
talk to you for an hour over an hour I
would just be like sweating you know it
would be a workout for me cuz it's just
the the amount of oxygen you're getting
in your lungs then you start to get
fatigued you get tired so it's just like
everything just kind of [__] adds up
on top of that you haven't been sleeping
cuz then you don't sleep not cuz you're
coked out but because if you got water
in your lungs you just not comfortable
to sleep like you start to go to sleep
and you start feeling the shortness of
breath you wake up like like you're
[__] drowning and [__] you know so
now this week now that she's back I'm
like you know what like you're you're my
Bal and it sucks that I'm a grown ass
man and people are watching at home like
you're F you're [__] adult bro like
all the [__] I've been through bro like
sometimes just having that one person
right there with you even just for them
to to for you to know that oh I can't
put down this whole pizza cuz my girl
right there she going to be like you fat
[__] or I can't snort this whole
eightball by myself cuz how am I going
to be around her I'm going kiss her and
she going to taste it in my [__]
mouth like it's just like is it sucks
that is that's the [__] that stops you
but for now is I'm going use it until I
can on my own just fall back from
everything you're not I think a lot of
us are like that if I wasn't married to
Rosie I I would be I we go to strip
clubs I would just be doing random wild
[__] all day yeah because it's like I
got to be responsible and take care of
her cuz we're we're my best homie that
will make you the best vers I'm going be
yeah I have to be the best thing cuz
it's like I got you're awesome I can't
be a shitty version for you and then
we're not together oh I'm going to get
my [__] together that's self d That's
the opposite yeah yeah you that's why I
told I told her too I was just like you
know what help me help you like yeah
like and you know I was just like I mean
yeah I'm I'm I'mma do it cuz for you
like cuz you get the responsibility like
now cuz she she I brought her from
Austin so she just came from Austin so
it's like she don't got no friends no
job nothing she's like all she got is me
out here and all I got her so I was like
I'm not about to like make you feel like
you left your life just to come Kang
with a junkie just cuz I'm got a little
bit of popularity or some [__] like I
want to you know give be a good spouse
or a good whatever a good a good partner
to you so in order for me to be a good
partner I got to be a good person of
myself and treat myself with respect and
treat myself better so you know it's
just like [__] I'm learning you feel me
like and back and back in the day like
growing up like you hang out with just
Street [__] like you ain't
nobody in relationships like you just
want to [__] and and throw like you
don't care about girls you like you care
about them just the [__] you know you
want nobody want to build anything but
then you get older and you mature you
know and and and sometimes just certain
vices don't let you mature all the way
that you want to but then this this
comes I feel like she's going to help me
get turn from like a boy into a man you
feel me nice we's see good yeah this is
a good path to be on though yeah I think
so cuz it's not going to get easier cuz
you're about to go across the whole
country over the next couple yeah yeah
we just we just announced the first leg
of the tour was only I think it's only
like 20 cities but we're going to
announce like 80 more so damn yeah yeah
so it's uh you going go to Montana
everywhere brother the best the best
name tour of all time come on man sorry
for the weight tour sorry for the weight
spelled weight as a dam big as [__] I I
feel it I love it and it's the real [__]
that's that's why people like I said
it's been under a year because people
are looking at you on stage going I feel
that [__] they like a damn that's how I
feel right now I didn't want to come out
cuz I'm all one and not even it's all
walks of life man not even just because
of drug content it's
just the reason I like to even talk
about this in in this from this point of
view when I do podcast is because in my
standup it seems like I glorify the drug
use and and I made the mistake of having
a few videos go viral from cocaine jokes
so a lot of the people that come to my
shows
they're or do a bum I do a meeting GRE
every time I finish a meeting GRE I'm
like a kid of Halloween I get to my
hotel room I empty my pockets sacks of
coke everywhere I sax a Coke sax a Coke
and [__] you don't be careful with that
[__] that'll be your last [__]
bump you know cuz you don't they don't
they don't not that nobody going to kill
you on purpose but they might not know
what they got you feel me going [__]
taking that [__] in Jersey doing coke
probably going to die you feel me like
so I just I started to discipline myself
and either not taking it or throwing it
away yeah and and it's funny cuz even
people that I tour with or that I used
to tour with like Martin amini who I
used to tour with he went and did a show
in Portland and I didn't come with him
to this specific date and somebody came
to his meeting greet and gave him a Coke
sa for me I give it to pass off I'm
going fly back with this [__] but and
that's another thing too like I was
getting too comfortable flying with that
[__] cuz you realize they don't even
look for that [__] I used to think think
that the dogs were for drugs then one
time I brought a [__] aball on
literally on accident and I got to the
[__] other city I'm like I walked
past the [__] dog I walked to TSA I
was like they don't they didn't find it
so instead of me being like let's not do
that again I was like we're doing this
[__] every [__] time so then you know
that could also lead into some [__]
so yeah you know it's just weird [__]
now is there a plan for like a special
or an hour that you're going to put out
anytime soon uh I'm not in a r for bro
cuz like we're in a new age you feel me
like like I know you guys are doing like
the YouTube stuff you know started with
the story times it's more a little bit
more traditional but you guys have also
shifted into the podcast which is like
the new age of content creation I feel
like for standup I'm selling out shows
300 seaters I'm selling out small
theaters in Texas with no special just
off Instagram Clips you feel me so
people put out a special to sell tickets
cuz nobody knows who they are we live in
a in in a world now that you can you
have the power to introduce yourself to
the world without putting a full body of
workout you know what I'm saying so I'm
what I'm trying to get at is I'm not in
a rush to put a special out although I
do have relationships with Netflix now
I've done their serious I've recorded
something for their serious exm and then
I'm also doing my I'm they're going to
run my hour at the main main room at The
Comedy Store forco de Mayo so they're
going to they're going to peep the hour
but if it doesn't happen I'm not gonna
be heartbroken or anything I would like
to record something at the end of the
year next year
and so that way I can put that material
out it doesn't get dated now most of my
comedy is pretty Timeless you know again
if it comes to like these stories and
stuff they never get old cuz they're you
you could just put a different Tim stamp
on it and I could tell you it happened
yesterday and it was still okay yeah
that makes sense you know so I would
like to do it just so I could not let
the jokes go to waste and and and also
the credit it's like um I'm a fan of
Comedy first of all you know like I'm
still every time I walk into The Comedy
Store The Improv like I walk in with my
head down I'm a student of the game and
I I see somebody that I've been you know
I see me and fluffy I mean you know just
being in the same room as him him
mentoring me it's just like the [__]
like the goat you feel me the goat you
you know and Dave Chappelle seeing him
like it's just like I'm in these rooms
like I just every day like sometimes
that's why also why I drink a lot cuz
like man ain't nobody doing what I'm
doing you know but then it's also like
it's also like damn like I'm grateful
and all this [__] so but and and I still
you want that special because it's like
um it's a it's it's a it's a certific
you know maybe not from even if nobody
watches it as long as the people in the
scene know oh he's got the Netflix thing
he's got the credit just for the credit
you know just for it to look good on on
paper you know it's like an album for a
music artist yeah you know like some
people get signed and they never get to
put on album they put on mixtapes and
[__] you know but but but for me to have
that special I will feel really good you
know if it does come out to Netflix or
or the platform it does come out to but
I'm not looking for it I'm not in the
hunt for it and if it never happens I
won't cry about it you know cuz I'm
already yourself is really want YouTube
you know now now YouTube is completely
like Shane Gill is one of my favorite
Comics blew up on YouTube you know
Jeffrey as is another comic I recommend
blew up on YouTube so it's definitely a
possibility to do that but there's also
a part of and I think every comedian
feels that way you still want that like
that Network you know the HBO the Amazon
it's a stand of like World approval
versus like my fan approval which is
what matters exctly but it's more like a
thanks for my grammy like
yeah you know like especially to like
going back to like making your parents
proud and [__] like that like I got
videos that got millions of views on
YouTube my dad don't give a [__] you
know like but if you see me on [__]
on a Netflix CU he'll be like oh even
though it probably got less views than
my [__] on YouTube You Know M people
just you know whatever there their [__]
is all over the place but but again I'm
already selling out venues that people
from Chicago that I came up with or
people that I look up to have credits
but they can't go to the venues I'm
going to and sell them out they can't
can't even sell halfway out you know
what I'm saying so it's like I'm already
blessed enough to do that and if I can
stay consistent enough to keep putting
out Clips maybe start doing more crowd
work so I could not doing more but
cutting more crowd work so I don't burn
through the material too but it's also
like like I'm it's kind of the thing the
the the Bing bad thing about jumping in
this game so fast is that people you get
agents you get management and they want
you to make money so they want to put
you on tour you hit Phoenix twice
already you know so now is and every
time I go back to I I've been to Phoenix
three times and the last time I went I
did two 400 ceders so it's 800 tickets
so now it's like they're looking at a
theater for next time you know but it's
like man I've been going back there and
like I've been doing new material and
[__] but like there's still a nice chunk
of my hour that's still the same [__]
you feel me cuz it's like my hits or my
Classics but the jokes that you know I
know that are going to work and it's
just like sometimes people there like if
they don't understand comedy and how it
works they're like Oh I thought you
going to come with new [__] like bro I
came a month ago you think I'm going to
come with a whole new hour in a month
you know like obviously not so that's
why this tour we finally released it as
a tour we got the name and everything
that we had under the name it'll be the
same hour and we're able to record it at
the end which we will record it even if
it's not sold yet we'll definitely have
to record it just to have the material
and then if it gets picked up it gets
picked up but but yeah man I'm I'm happy
with where I'm at bro honestly yeah at
your end of your career you'll look back
and you'll have those like you know kind
of the different chapters of your career
yeah yeah and it it was crazy cuz like
my [__] will always be out like
Instagram is not going to go away you
know and even if it does the videos
there the internet yeah this is year
this is year one I mean like like you're
ready you're announcing your [__] you're
going you're getting the approval from
all these people you're doing your [__]
and what you're about to start your is
it across the country or not world right
across country not the world yet I don't
got a passport but I'm working on that
but but across the country right now but
I'm going like I the first markets I had
already hit was like Houston you know
all the Texas all the Cali Phoenix the
Midwest they they [__] with me cuz I'm
from Chicago New York but now I'm
hitting like the Toledo Ohio Cleveland
Ohio Syracuse New York Albany New York
Nebraska all those [__] that I never
even heard of so it's just I huntville
Alabama I went last week and people are
coming you know like maybe now I'm not
maybe I'm not selling out the 300 CER in
Hunt of Alabama but 100 [__]
came sh 100 [__] 100
[__] you feel me like and next
time it'll be 150 or maybe we'll sell it
out so I'm going just keep staying
consistent learning I mean getting
opportunities like this is always a
blessing cuz I'm sure somebody will find
me from this and be like hey man I [__]
with you on there I check out your stand
up it was good we hear that all the time
from people come on the of course so
thank you guys you know for the
opportunity appreciate you and and like
I said before we started you can get to
know somebody on stage you get it but
they're not you're not going to get
you're not going to get like you can't
get everything so these podcasts is a
way to open up like we introduced I mean
everybody knows josa but maybe people
our audience didn't know and now they're
they're [__] fans and it just keeps
going Ryan you know I mean fluffy and it
just it's just a an evergoing cycle I
feel of fans if they they like you on
the show they're G going to watch you
when they come to your town like damn
he's in my town I'm going to go mhm and
that and that's how it works and I think
like the new age this is this is the
flyer this is the radio spots you would
do in every city you don't got to do
that right now you just do this and
go fire done yep that's it that's it
that's that's really it bro and it's
crazy cuz like I wish more people would
cuz I'm not the funniest person to come
out of Chicago at all and now there's
people that are still doing bar shows
that are funnier than me but the thing
is we live in a world that you got to
adapt you know yeah and if you don't
adapt like if you want to came over to
the podcast World maybe your income
would have been a lot less you feel me
or something like that but if you jump
on it quick now you're one of the
biggest you know podcast on Spotify or
what not you know so it's like if you
don't jump on it early and adapt to that
[__] you're going to get left behind you
know and I feel like I already got left
behind from when I fell off the YouTube
[__] the first time so I was like I
already fell off I can't fall off again
I can't afford to fall off again cuz I
especially with the addictions I got all
the devices if I might fall off like not
lit not literally but you know I might
just be like well I'm a [__] you know
I'm do whole bunch of Co you know like
so it's just like you know what this is
the only thing I've ever loved and the
only thing I've ever stayed true to and
consistent to I've had a lot of
commitment issues everything I've ever
started I've quit so this [__] that I'm
doing is like I'm not going to give up
this is going to be the [__] key to
to make my family proud my people from
my hometown proud especially people that
grew up the way I grew up that maybe
don't got the comedic talent but they
don't want to be in that garage at 4:00
a.m. doing coke they want to they want
to have a way out like let me be the
motivation to maybe maybe if you like
fixing cars and [__] you know or or
[__] anything else just or stacking
money work more hours at your job even
if I give you that motivation to do that
[__] I I want to be that for for that
person you know and I to to motivate the
the youth the people you know what I'm
saying like from where I'm from MH
that's the whole point of the show yeah
that's the whole point of what a wrap up
message
that was perfect uh before we go where
can everybody find your uh your tour how
can they get tickets uh you get tickets
at Ken fes.net uh you can name all my
social medias are Ken Flores
3000 um I got links on link tree and
then Kemp fl.net my official website
where you'll find all my headlining
dates uh for any cities and then any
future cities once we announce the next
leg of the tour will it will be on there
I know I don't know what's up with
people man you tell people like this is
the first leg of the tour if you don't
see your city it will be added then I
get a paragraph why the [__] you not
coming to Sacramento bro hey man I told
you said it I'm coming Man Press more
yeah man it's just like but that's what
I say put it on the flyer put it on the
flyer cuz fools will not look yeah or
read yeah but but I'm coming I'm coming
everywhere sorry for the weight yep
sorry for the weight all right all right
and uh all I'm sorry all I keep
imagining all I'm going to keep keep
imagining is you taking the towel off
that bed and putting it back that's all
I keep thinking of cuz I keep thinking
of the Box the sun coming in the wood I
got a once we get off camera on my
Snapchat I don't know if you got
Snapchat but my memories and Snapchat as
as I'm walking away from the RV I
snapped a picture
no I got a picture of the RV that should
be the next tour post and it's funny cuz
I used to do the podcast and I and I I
don't know no it's been years it's been
at least five years now but I mean I I
mean I hope it's not there but but but I
remember like talking telling this whole
story on the podcast
and at the time I still had the
conversation on my phone the thread so I
would upload on my podcast page like the
thread of it talking and then the
picture of the the the [__] RV so I'm
like putting I'm putting like the I'm
putting the [__] pictures to the
stories and [__] you know but I lost all
the threads of the text messages and I
had the same phone but I still do got
that picture of the RV you don't make
that up no hell no you don't put
yourself in that life yeah hell
no and the type of Comedy I do the
reason I came and tell this like I don't
I don't want people people that think
that I came up here and started doing my
bits or anything like that cuz nothing
that I told you today is in my standup
that story I I tell a comedy if you ever
been to one of my shows or you watch my
Clips my comedy is very fast-paced and
that's because I don't have I'm not okay
with silence so I always feel like I
need validation immediately so when I'm
up there like even if I'm telling a
longer joke you'll have boom five punch
lines or five [__] that'll make you
laugh so you don't even know when the
actual punch line hits you know so that
story I Can't Tell It On Stage because
of all the times that it's quiet that
you would just be looking at me
listening I get uncomfortable telling it
and I might rush through it and I can't
tell it comfortable and a podcast
setting is different it's easier to tell
but for me telling it in front of a
[__] 300 people I'm going to be like
and then you was sucking my titty uh and
if I don't get a laugh right there I'm
going to start panicking you know I
don't want to make [__] up either cuz
it's I want to tell it how it happened
you know yeah yeah so maybe in the
future though yeah that pacing and panic
you just did I never even thought of it
but tell a story online on stage like
yeah you can't bro there's like eight
minutes of me doing this what the [__]
yeah yeah yeah [__] that [__] touched
my hair yeah it's weird it's weird bro
yeah it's hard to describe and podcast
setting is so much fun dude there's
nobody sitting here just W to laugh this
like it's this is 4 p.m. garage talk not
4:00 a.m. doing coke rage talk that's
what podcasts are the 400 PM talks yeah
all right and we're ship based drunk
maybe it's different different podcast
we have had some wild ass shows on here
before but no this was fun as hell dude
I don't even remember I just keep I just
keep having the image of a sticky
blanket with a towel and I can't get it
out of my head you've been talking about
other [__] it's still there it's nasty
as hell nasty nasty oh it's so [__]
gross but funny though dude um so uh Ken
Flores 300 on everything Ken fes.net to
get tickets and to see dates yep when
you announcing the next leg of the tour
uh I don't have it middle of January oh
okay so soon people got time yeah oh
yeah that'll be that'll be from after
April so like May through like August
and this is the first episode of the new
year right yeah this the first the first
episode hell yeah man good [__] man hell
excited man you're going to crush it
you're going to keep taking it in a
positive direction this time next year
you're going to have all these [__]
dates under your belt you're going to be
a whole different Beast appreciate you
guys man yeah of course man I'm just
riding it you know like I said I feel
like I shouldn't even be here I told you
when I came in I'm like I'm star strick
bro like I I used to sit at home do
drugs and watch this [__] watch Goblin's
gameplay hear him tell stories about the
city I'm from getting pulled over
getting GE as [__] having his homie trip
off acid and haven't seen his face for
the first time on your [__] like this
[__] look like this
like like cuz you know like he says I
don't look like the person that you
think I yeah exactly but but it's just
like so having all that put together
with the background that I have the drug
use I've done and then like the your
backgrounds is the stories you tell like
getting high at the Park Police come all
that I remember all that [__] so for us
to be here sitting and telling
exchanging story now it's just like I
already made like I'm I'm good man like
I'm happy for what's to come but I
already feel like I'm way further than I
should ever be oh I appreciate you man
I'm just hyped that you're hyped that
just [__] awesome but that's why I
think that's like I said once again
won't be to death but that's why the
comedy connects cuz like people are
going to watch this and go I get it I
get it cuz like you're saying you watch
my [__] like this F really SM oh he does
SM I'm going to watch this [__] and then
people it's it's just a ever it's a
circle that just keeps [__] going
dude and it's a Content game right now
because you're what Mak [__] on you're
putting out your standup online which is
basically just clips and selling your
tickets you don't got to do the radio I
know beating in the ground but this is
this is the new wave this is how it's
going I'm hype for you this is awesome
to see your first tour first episode of
the year I'm excited yo by next year we
both should be in better shape that's a
goal to be like yo I'll take it step by
step little by little just you're dude I
strug well fluffy on here what did you I
thought about it when my back was hurt
last week I was getting out of the
shower and I was like oh and I remember
Fluffy's like my weight is the only
thing I haven't been able to to kill to
crush yet I Crush everything else in
life but that's the one thing I haven't
conquer I went damn it he struggle with
I'm like I got to get this [__] under
control and you're telling me the same
thing like I just want to be here when
I'm an old man you know what I mean like
I I got to be here as an old man I want
to let that fool from Blood In Blood Out
magic that's what I look like would be
buffing in shaped Yeah Yeah Yeah Chris
far I said Chris Farley's a perfect
example like like man it's like I watch
his documentary and they talk about all
the stuff he struggled with and it's
just like damn it that's me like it's me
but he
already he already did what he had to do
the sacrifice of losing him so young so
I could learn from that you know so it
would be dumb for me to keep going and
do go out the same way you feel me so
he's like he can't go this far and then
just crash out the same way like for
nothing you feel me so it's just like I
got to make the change so sh next time
this next year this time we're both
going to be skiner yeah see that's the
way you do it man cuz he was too funny
and I just want to be able to it was so
sad seeing Adam Sandler sit there we
just saw manim and he was like singing a
tribute song to him at the end that was
his friend [__] is like all this time
later it's still just him thinking about
his friend yeah and it sucks because
it's like people I got friends around me
that tell me too you got to slow down
bro you got to chill but it doesn't
matter what anybody says nobody can do
it until you don't want to do it you
feel me so you better figure out sooner
than later I feel like right now I'm at
the time where it's like I'm realizing
this is not what I want so now I got to
put in the work to get away from it you
know it's only going to make you more
it's only make you better it's going to
make you more money you're going to feel
better like all everything is positive
there's not that there's one negative
yeah there's not one negative to be like
let me get in shape why so I'm buffer
and cooler I can jump higher
period that's it like I want to be able
to get off of a deep couch and not go
damn
it yeah spre my leg kind of far yeah my
couch is deep as [__] right now bro like
just to get up like I can't get up
without farting you feel me like I'm
putting so much [__] you know
pressure and that [__] to just try to
get up it's like [__] man like I
shouldn't be off out of breath getting
up you know and people and it's funny
cuz like you could also see it in my
standup and people always comment
they're like damn bro like like if
somebody gets a friend that at one of my
jokes they be like oh that's why you
can't breathe fat ass which I'm already
like I don't really give [__] cuz I'm a
comedian you feel me I got thick skin
but it's just like man like I don't want
I don't want to be that obvious you know
I don't want you to be at home being
able to notice that I can't breathe you
feel me like [__] it's in M that's part
of the
set yeah I have this joke where I talk
about catching my breath and I have and
and it's a joke that I do that for and I
always look forward to doing that joke
just so I can catch my breath for real
little extra sometimes I do it earlier
in my set just so I could reset you know
I'm going to throw I'm going to throw
one in where I like yeah then you know
you fix your underwear like this just so
I can fix my [__] underwear peel the
balls off your legs damn it all right
man we're going to keep going this [__]
but thank you so much for being here
sorry for the weight tour is officially
started yep officially started uh second
leg of the tour if you don't see it on
Ken fes.net he will announce it what mid
mid January mid January right around so
about a week and a half after this
episode comes out first episode of the
Year Marty anything else you want to add
we appreciate you being here I feel like
this this needed to happen yeah this is
fun man this is fun dud man appreciate
you feels like you've been one of our
boys for a long time and we appreciate
you watching and supporting it was great
to hear you say I hit up an old friend I
used to watch a show with and [__] let
them know I was coming like just that
that [__] means a lot so yeah shout out
my boy JV man I appreciate you man and
remember uh was it Ken Flores 300 on all
socials check it out guys thank you so
much for being here Marty thank you for
being here Ken fles guys thank you so
much I'm extremely burnt and high for
someon like I'm high this episode it was
a different kind of we it's been about a
month since we smoked on the podcast for
maybe that's what it also you're I know
we're supposed to get out but man the
you're a good Storyteller man I was lost
in that Shick I see every little crevice
of that [__] RV that little baby's 5
years old right now it that was sad yeah
man watching this episode yeah right
watching this episode scroll it like
this cuz Tik Tok uh shorts [__] his
brain up yeah all right we're going to
get out of here before we keep doing
this all right thank you so much
appreciate you for being here guys this
has been the dope as usual podcast thank
you for watching have a dope ass day
yeah that was fun man that was
[Music]
ridiculous
perfect
[Music]